as promised
protesters from netflix people who work
there came out saying trans lives matter
they were protesting against dave
chappelle and what they said was bigotry
and hate speech
and i think it was exactly what we
thought was going to happen man i'm just
going to say it this group of
individuals was completely deranged and
and i mean it and i'm not saying that in
any way disrespectful to the actual
individuals who have questions about uh
hate speech because this clearly was
deranged unhinged made no sense there
was no there was no uh argument or or
conversation brought up around what
their ideas were supposed to represent
it was just insanity and you think i may
be exaggerating no no no
there was a guy there at the netflix hq
holding a sign saying we like jokes or
something i like dave chappelle and they
attacked him tore his his sign
grabbed his sign destroyed it and it
just said something like we like dave
and they start screaming he's got a
weapon then a woman comes up to him with
some kind of shaker and says like demon
be gone or something trying to exercise
him so yes if you came to me and said
i'd like to have a conversation about
hate speech on netflix i'd be like all
right well here we go let's hear it that
wasn't even this it was completely
deranged but you know what
netflix their co-ceo i think is
individual is is already beginning to
cave saying you know maybe i should have
been a bit more careful and recognized
that employees are hurting oh shut up
did you see this this video guy do you
know who you're talking about why are
you hiring these people trying to
exercise a guy who says i like dave
chappelle
yeah great well this is interesting so
definitely to talk about this we got
chicago police officers still defying
the vax mandates and boy is crime uh
going up and uh we're gonna have to get
into this plus the the the january 6
committee has referred stephen bannon to
they were they've they've moved to seek
criminal prosecution of bannon meaning
it's got to go to a floor vote probably
will never happen but
still
this is the uh the realm of politics we
are in right now where the establishment
is literally saying we'll do what we can
to try and put you in prison even though
steve bannon was not there at the
capitol didn't happen and they could go
after antifa they could go after these
lunatics who burned down buildings nope
steven bannon's got bad opinions and he
helped organize a rally where people
waved little american flags get him
well joining us to talk about all these
ideas we got jack pacobic what's going
on tim i had my first time in the new
studio i was a little a little
disoriented but fortunately i slept on a
my pillow last night
and the topper
i did i've been traveling a little bit
and it's always annoying when you travel
because you don't have you know i don't
have to fold my pillow with me when i'm
traveling and it just you know you don't
get the best sleep so i was in denver i
was out there i was speaking um at the
centennial institute then on friday i
was over in phoenix got to visit turning
point headquarters where i got the swag
here and um you know but it's always
nice to get home and you know i mean of
course you know for my family and my
children but also also my mindfulness
what what a great salesman i'm taking
notes i know right and uh i just
launched a new klaus schwab t-shirt that
i just posted on twitter and instagram
under lukeweerchange and if you're
interested in the new klaus schwab swag
you could get it
the best political shirts dot com or the
shirt that i'm wearing right now that
you know makes sure that the npcs
understand that they should only trust
verified sources and no one else
everybody's always selling something you
guys you come on my show and you start
talking about the things you're going to
sell and it's almost as if you aren't
getting enough bio trucks
yeah i don't have anything to sell but
boris johnson might be uh making magic
mushrooms legal i don't think we're
going to talk about it on the show much
but just want to get that out there get
ahead of the curve on that one oh good
for you heading over in you you're going
to be first in line yeah i'll take a dip
you're going for it yeah you're not
going to be able to get in because of
all the weird lockdowns and restrictions
i think you need vaccine to go to uk
right now yeah you can't even do it like
zooby was saying he had to like fly to
another country and they did he couldn't
just come to the us some people were
telling me that uh for poland actually
they were saying that you can't fly
direct but if you fly into like
frankfurt then you can go over or
something so weird because it depends on
where you go through schengen wow
i am also here in the corner i am
pushing buttons as i usually do i am
intrigued by all this talk of my pillow
i actually sent two of them to my
husband what i did was i air sucked all
the air out of them with my vacuum and
they traveled just like a dream it's
amazing you could totally take them with
you is what i'm saying oh yeah they
would compress pretty well they compress
yeah but then you need to so when you
when you open them up
you have to put in the dryer so you know
if i don't have a dryer with me on
basically what i need to do is every
time i'm traveling somewhere i need to
send it ahead with it with full
instructions right you're going to open
this up you're going to un-vacuum seal
it you're going to put it in the dryer
and have it prepared on my bed for me
it'll be in my rider like when i go out
for a dryer
only you know a bowl of m m's uh red
only red only m m's then another bowl of
skittles yellow only and then full my
pillows everywhere
well there you go yes well my friends we
do have something to pitch head over to
timcast.com become a member and you will
get access to exclusive members only
segments from this show we're gonna have
a members only segment coming up we do
it uh monday through thursday's 11 pm
but now we have the green room fridays
and that's where we just film people
hanging out doing fun stuff in our green
room but right now you will see on the
front page of timcast.com we have round
two
bid now to win two tickets to hang out
with tim cast live we are doing an event
it's in the harpers ferry area all the
tickets were tickets were all free from
members who are 25 or more so this is an
event we're doing where we're just
everyone's going to get like you get i
think two drink tickets again the
tickets were free now we're doing the
members only auction and so you can
actually go if you're a member and bid
if you want to try and come and then
every day we're going to have another
auction with two more tickets that'll
run for about a day and then uh yeah
definitely check out the website but
don't forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this channel and share the
show with your friends if you're on a
podcast or whatever give us five stars
because that really helps
well let's get into the news my friends
we got this from fox netflix protesters
furious over chappelle special attack
man with we like dave's what i can't get
the screen to work you can't get the
screen to work something's funny with
the screen what did you do i don't i
didn't do it this wasn't me for watching
yeah it's weird right oh man yeah okay
what happened i'm not sure i switched
the input
enjoy our technical glitch here you put
the camera to me
probably the best thing you can do all
night uh-oh there you go well
i guess i'll uh i'll read i'll read the
story and uh at least everyone else can
see it well we could use that camera to
uh put that on the screen right and that
could work i mean bootleg i'm i'm great
and stuff so just take take the long
view camera put it on the screen it's
not as long as it used to be well yeah
we got a new ptz camera we'll just we'll
just read the news
yeah i trust you trust me i'm reading
the news
all right here we go my friends about
that from fox news netflix protesters
furious over chappelle special attack
man with we like dave sign no no they
didn't attack a man with a sign that
said we like dave they attacked a man
holding a sign that said we like dave i
think the title is kind of funny some
activists have called for netflix to
remove the controversial dave chappelle
special everyone spells dave chappelle
wrong by the way that's that's always
look at this yeah i was just wondering
that actually it's two p's right yes
how dare they
so this video is just absolutely
hilarious by the way and i guess we're
not getting any sound either
so uh there you can see there it's just
a sign that says we like to actually you
can't see anything you can't see
anything
i'll tell you what's happening
there's a guy holding up a sign that
says we like dave the crowd the mob
surrounds him just stomps on it destroys
it and then starts screaming he's got a
weapon what this is amazing there's a
tweet from the daily wire if someone
wants to go check it out yeah yeah yeah
so i think i think netflix loves this
you think so i think i think they love i
think that's why the was it the vice
president uh came out and talked about
taking it's oh i'm so sorry i apologize
we never should have done this but you
notice he didn't take it down right
because this thing is doing gangbusters
in terms of views and more controversy
means more people are going to view it
so at the end of the day i think netflix
is secretly very happy all this is going
on they might be organizing the protest
i mean you're kidding from a marketing
perspective if you've got a book coming
out if you've got something coming out
and protesters are going to come out
there after you given today's
environment yeah that's what you want
it's exactly what you want well they
well the mainstream media was talking
about a thousand employees walking out
of netflix i think it's safe to say that
it definitely wasn't a thousand people
it was some people that went vapid and
crazy because one guy had a sign and
stood there peacefully saying we like
dave and they responded as if he was he
was kind of criminal i'm pretty sure he
was chanting trans lives matter too
he wasn't opposed to me she's like i
like dave he's a funny guy and they were
so screaming at him a couple guys jumped
on him took his sign down ripped it away
tore it apart and then made sure he
couldn't have it he had a stick they
said the stick was weapon they pushed
him and they came up and they said free
speech mf her and they got really close
oh lady was like shaking
she was like
so i saw dave chappelle in
in nevada a couple of weeks before this
thing dropped it was right before the um
the mcgregor fight because we were out
for that and it was will chamberlain's
bachelor party and we're with tom sauer
and a bunch of people and
so that was one of those sort of like no
you know no cell phone shows but i think
that a lot of the similar kind of bits
and stories that he was telling at that
show and rogan came and did like the
opening act and um tatsugure was there
as well and i remember one of the big
things that chappelle was talking about
that night and i've heard that it's he
repeats the story again on the special
is that he had a very close friend who
was a fan she was trans and then was
bullied for being friends with dave
chappelle and then ends up killing
herself and he was sort of just telling
her story and saying how
he's like you can be friends with
someone who's trans you can treat them
respectfully but this movement right the
politization of it has gotten out of
hand and oh by the way my friend died as
a result of this dave's losing this did
he lose him absolutely losing his his uh
sticks and stones was hilarious it was
amazing it was offensive he did that's
the last special not not this one is the
closer the latest one it is the closer
you're saying that's the special best
sticks and stones the one before was
amazing what happened he got attacked
but we all joked saying they can't get
dave chappelle he's too famous he's too
big everybody likes the guy right right
but they did put a crack in the hole
and if you watch the closer man half of
the bid is basically him complaining
about getting attacked for it no that
was the whole show when i saw him too it
was actually it was a little bit jealous
i fell asleep i fell asleep during the
show i was like got to his head where's
the where's the comedy where's that and
then he said i'm not going to do these
jokes anymore because i don't think they
get it it's like he's caving in wow now
the netflix ceo is like oh i should have
uh did it better because our employees
are hurting and then you get all of
these psycho this cult and it's a cult
man when they start screaming evil be
gone and they're acting as if they're in
some kind of like
hollow fundamental simulacrum of a
religion or something
they have lost their screaming burn the
witch is that what they're screaming no
i'm i'm saying but i'm paraphrasing
right that it's that's a i'm drawing a
parallel between that that it's they've
declared that dave chappelle is a witch
and that anybody who supports him well
then you're also going along so let's
take a look at like amy schumer's
netflix special everybody hated it it
was yeah i mean awful well just think of
all those clips that went viral of the
great jokes from amy schumer that we've
all
yeah exactly and the controversy there
there was some clips because she was
saying just really disgusting things
and people thought she was trying to go
for like shock content oh yeah
yeah she was talking about she talks a
lot about disgusting bodily functions
right and uh people were just like i
don't understand how i relate to this
and so that's when netflix got rid of
the star system and said we're gonna do
a thumbs up thumbs down i guess is that
what they do thumbs up thumbs down now
or something
so something like that but it's it's so
annoying to me because i liked the tsar
system when they had that right yeah you
know you should be able to see okay do
people like this thing is it any good
how much which amazon has on prime you
can actually see that and there's other
services out there other streaming
services will at least give like the
imdb score so you have some kind of an
idea but netflix it's gone
now we have dave chappelle who is wildly
popular audience loved the show even
though this one was very much him like
eulogizing you know his career like i
can't do this anymore i'm not going to
be doing a special he talked so much
about how they went after him and how
his friend died over it and he's he's
he's like basically saying like i can't
do this
so now
they're they're protesting outside of
netflix they're getting what they want
the ceo is starting to back down he's
like i should have thought about this
and the cracks are forming dave
chappelle was a much harder target to
get to get taken down but they're
succeeding
yeah and the more you allow this to
continue the more you say well i'm going
to go along with it even though you know
it's ridiculous and you know he's
clearly wasn't saying anything that was
negative any of the stuff these doesn't
even matter not anything they accuse him
of you are giving them a win you're
giving them a win because you're letting
them set the frame of the debate you're
letting them set the narrative and
you're bending the knee at the end
you're bending the knee this reminds me
of uh south park when the hippies are
coming to south park yeah they want to
do the music festival they arrest
cartman and then they're like this
festival is going to be great for us
eric why would you try and stop it we're
going to make tons of money and there's
like hippies doubt have money
and then that ends up happening wait
until the corporations hear the sick
groove yeah exactly it's like and then
he plays um he plays slayer and gets
bloodrayne by slayer and gets everyone
to go away but isn't that the one where
they have the um they have like the van
that they drive through the crowd yeah
they're like don't go out there
yeah it's like the movie the court but i
i bring that up because
dave chappelle popular funny and netflix
is slowly being weakened by
a horde of deranged people screaming
psychotic things
why is anyone listening to these people
meanwhile
it's good for the establishment i guess
to control culture i haven't seen clips
of any of that of dave chappelle going
viral but i'll tell you what clips are
going viral it's north macdonald right
the north mcdonald clips the stuff that
people are digging up for from
throughout his career and the reason he
was popular was because he was
politically incorrect and he would say
things that if there was a sacred cow he
would step on it and mock it and make
fun of it and criticize it in a way that
you know whether it was hillary clinton
or o.j simpson or whatever literally
whatever it was
he was even making fun of the way
democrats were spinning january 6th if
you go to his twitter feed there's a few
tweets of him
i think from the day actually from that
very day and
you know that was his entire career
because he was just being real do you
think that's what people want you see
they're going after jon stewart now good
he deserves it he deserves every bit of
it jon stewart but why why does john
stewart deserve it because he's a
horrible person you think so he's
disgusting person he's responsible for
the gamification of politics he's one of
the people along with very much him very
much yes if you look at what he did with
the daily show he decided that and he
went on and then he goes on a crossfire
right and it was tucker right
and that was the show where they had one
it was always it started with buckley
and they would always have sort of one
conservative one liberal and they would
sit down and they would debate but they
would at least have a conversation jon
stewart goes on a crossfire blows it up
and says you shouldn't be talking to
each other we shouldn't have
conversations with each other instead he
then he goes over to the daily show and
what does he do no he's not really a
political guy he didn't come to um to
media with any kind of political
background but he what did he know he
knew talk radio and specifically sports
radio and so he turned the daily show
and indeed was a pop culture show right
a pop culture show originally under
craig kilbourne which was fantastic
um
that he turned it into essentially
sports radio but his team was the
democrats i mean
jon stewart praised project vertos on
more than one occasion
when well i think he's i think he's
trying to atone right now but this is
this is back in the day i think he's
trying to the run of the daily show i
can't give it to him no can't give it to
him well relative to where we're at now
you know his willingness to be like look
at this guy and look what he did and now
you have you know john oliver jordan
clepper jim jeffries
garbage trash
for sure my theory is
that stuart started that yeah but the
weaponization of comedy there's a big
difference between someone who's like
here are things that i think we should
talk about and then someone being like
hey look at this formula we can extract
from that right but think of it too this
way it he changes the formula of comedy
as opposed instead of i think you're
putting it on him when it's when it's
comedy central when it's when it's hbo
when it's these to an extent but how
many years was he the host of the daily
show
eight seasons or something nine seasons
was it was it nine it was it was a long
time it was a long time yeah it was like
a really long time and so he changed it
from instead of the punch line being so
the idea of you know like a normal
mcdonald where the idea of a punch line
is a um you know you're not you're
you're
forgetting this phrase but you're giving
you're not giving someone their
expectations right you're subverting
expectations you're an unexpected
punchline he took that away he took away
the punch line and so the punch line
became look at these stupid people they
think things that are different than us
he hosted it for 16 years 16 99 2015.
well now he's come out and he's sad
believes it was 2015. he said the media
is focusing too heavily on trump acting
like he's the greatest threat and we
need to you know get back to reality and
now they're all saying because he did
johnson
the entire time the entire i'm sorry
like i just don't buy any of the jon
stewart like you know retribution tour i
don't i don't i don't know because i
remember i don't know
hold on
the same thing bill maher is like all of
a sudden now i'm playing to a mixed
audience and people are craving comedy
mocking wokeness
and it's like yes bill because people
who are liberal back then
are still the same political same
politically but we watch videos of these
this group of unhinged psychopaths
outside of netflix and i'm supposed to
relate to that as the left
please
now jack i would disagree with you a
little bit because i believe bush
deserved a lot of criticism and he was
only getting it on jon stewart and some
other shows but but everyone especially
early on in his presidency
but he was also one of the few people
that actually criticized obama and was
actually able to break that barrier now
i understand your bigger point when he
kind of politicized comedy and wielded
it as a weapon i think more effectively
than anybody else out there and he did
it for his side and i think you make a
compelling argument about that um
of all those he's patient zero this
wasn't you know and then when jimmy
jimmy kimmel is kind of like you know a
great example of someone who became
infected by this right you can go and
see jimmy kimmel early on when he's
doing um it was the game show he had
with ben stein and then he's on the man
show
and then when ben stein's money win
benson's money yeah he was
the host of that yeah obviously yeah
colbert was twisted and then you know
and that yeah even colbert originally
was just kind of like a parody but then
right they go through this filter they
pass through this filter they realize
the weaponization of it they realize the
political power of comedy and now you
turn it on and every single i don't
i don't think i don't think uh it starts
with stewart i don't think you'll be
starting that's pretty i don't think a
bunch of democrats were like wow look
how powerful this is i think certainly
there were some what i think happened
was after the daily show was was winding
down
every episode is the exact same pretty
much literally it's like mysterious
lupus
it's yeah it's it's always sarcoidosis
and then you know it is always
sarcoidosis yeah yes but but thinking
about how formulaic that is watch watch
john oliver's show and it is a beat for
beat identical every single episode
truth be damned there was a um there was
a 4chan thread about john oliver that
was like went viral on twitter and other
places where they were talking about how
uh john oliver and their use of canned
laughter and canned applause and their
pause lines and the fact that they won't
probably think right now it's
programmatic it's completely predictive
program and then when kovet hid they had
no audience and their shows were tanking
because they had to use laugh tracks and
it wasn't the same thing as a studio
audience being told to applaud because
every studio audience that goes there
they're told hey guys you got to give
this a lot of energy you got to clap you
got to go crazy did you see the the
trevor noah
during the pandemic yeah i loved it have
you ever have you ever seen have you
ever seen stripping theory without the
laugh track no they they take an episode
of big bang theory and they remove all
the laugh track and then you realize
there's not a single joke in the entire
show it'll be like
sheldon will come and he'll go
what are you doing making popcorn
yes i'm making popcorn yeah big bang
theory sucks that's it
that's that's that's funny that's what
john oliver is too yeah take away the
laughing and he's like little timothy
over here these you know
uh of this comment but
john oliver and trevor noah any of these
guys couldn't hang with even like a
basic youtuber like none of them could
walk through that door and be able to
hang on the show well everything
everything is scripted everything's
carefully curated and it's kind of sad
what happened to comedy because just a
few years ago we had jon stewart was
funny like i'll give him that he has a
ton of talent i just don't respect it
all the way but but but still you
compare today's comedians to bill hicks
richard pryor george carlin eddie murphy
oh yeah those people leaned into
controversy and used it as a way to make
fun of orthodoxies to question the
narratives and to bring attention to
themselves and to their art now and i
think i think some people are
criticizing tim's point here about
dave kind of bowing down but but i wish
kind of dave would have kind of embraced
it more he made it very serious and i
wish he he you know he he did it because
he genuinely wanted to do it but i wish
he would have ended by just slam dunking
as much as he could and just going over
the top and just bringing it to a point
where again laughter was the focus and
not seriousness because when he does
walk away from it and says i'm done guys
and he kind of nods his head and he's
unhappy he does kind of open up this
window that allows this larger protest
to come in to fill that vacuum that he
sucked out of that room that he sucked
out of that stadium with that
seriousness so i you know when it came
through richard
when i saw dave chappelle that's exactly
what the feeling was like and he was
still working on that gig he ends with
his friend killing herself and that's
like the end of the show and that's and
that's you know and you leave and you're
like
what was that well that goes into the
whole kind of negative energetic circle
but we have to ask ourselves what would
george carlin do what would richard
pryor do in these situations and they
would double down triple down and make
fun of this entire situation because
there's a lot of comedy here that video
of of of the guy saying we like dave
getting harassed i mean there's so much
room to work with and we're living in a
situation where we can't even laugh at
these things are we going to be
threatened to be censored or canceled no
i don't want to live like that i want to
live with people standing up and and and
and fighting for one of the most
important rights there is and that's the
right to have satire
so that's my point of view and i always
said it's going to be a dark day when
the sensors the youtubes figure out how
to go after satire and i think they're
encroaching on dave and it's not going
to end with dave but dave
you know again i i like that special but
i wish there was more i wish there was
more of a more of a more of a ending on
i'm still going to laugh at you guys
cowards and cultists took over our major
institutions our media our and big tech
i remember uh twitter free speaking of
the free speech party
wow huh i don't know what happened to
jack dorsey and his crew but they
immediately just dropped to their knees
and said you know i will do whatever you
say
and now you end up with netflix i think
they were always cowards if you look at
hollywood but now it's just transparent
with the internet
industry is so disgusting for so long i
still is i definitely think jack dorsey
is a coward i definitely definitely
think that because you know talking to
him privately when i did back in you
know several years ago now he was
talking about the need for people to uh
you know have their social media be
immutable and you can't take people down
and things like that he was talking
about how we need a path to redemption
just banning someone permanently for
these infractions is is not you know
it's not just and he does nothing yeah
it was kind of amazing when you'd hear
him say that stuff and i remember
listening to your um your i wouldn't
call it a throw down but discussion
right and it almost sounds like jack
dorsey the person
does still kind of have that feeling
right but he's a coward but he doesn't
do anything about it and you hear oh
yeah path to redemption that sounds good
or like a rehabilitation program or any
of these various things and yet none of
them ever come to fruition and you just
kind of get the sense that this guy is
not the one who's actually in control of
his coming what would be good
did you hear about dan bongino saying
that he would he's gonna he's gonna quit
his program of cumulus right cumulus
over their vaccine mandate yeah i'm
curious what you think about that well
so the context just real quick is dan
bungino he's got like his show is on
over 300 different radio networks right
he's signed to uh with a company called
westwood one which is part of the
cumulus radio network and he said if
that company cumulus wants to have a
vaccine mandate then i will quit this
show unless they stop you can either
have the vaccine medic or you can have
me now i've got a lot of thoughts now
but i'm curious what you think
and dan by the way and one thing i did
see with that one wrinkle is that he is
personally vaccinated because he had uh
cancer issues so he was someone uh who
obviously is immunocompromised i have a
friend um who had throat cancer is just
getting over that and he's like
he needs to wear a mask all the time
right and it it makes sense right
because he's immunocompromised you know
as far as dan i think that's amazing i
think that's fantastic i think you know
i was one of the guys that i got
freedom flu going worldwide and it was
the number one trend on twitter and this
is between southwest it wasn't just the
weather um and delta and the rest of the
people in the military and everything
that's going forward is you need to
stand up against medical tyranny and i
think that's what he's doing i think
he's looking at it from a perspective of
i don't want to live in a country where
we mandate things like this when it look
if
and i saw people saying this when i was
tweeting about it someone had commented
and they said well what if kovid was 10
times more deadly right and what if this
and i said well what if what you know i
live in reality where do you live right
like yeah what if it made people turn
into vampires yeah
what if it whatever right it but the
point is it doesn't but for some reason
you people have deluded yourselves into
thinking that covet is something that
it's not i i have a really simple answer
to a lot of the the the pro-mended
people they're like well what about all
the other vaccines that we mandate like
mmr and i'm like i've never been
mandated to get vaccinated to go to the
store or buy a slice of pizza right no
one has right so we're not something
entirely different so for example right
when i was in the military right so when
you first join you go through boot camp
um you go through you go down what's
called vaccine alley right in vaccine
alley it's like left arm right arm left
arm right and they tell you what it is
they're like oh this is that you don't
remember like this is this one this is
that one this is this one that's that
one you're just left arm right arm left
and right and the last one well it goes
somewhere else but yeah
and then and then when i went to
guantanamo um because we were with the
afghan detainees and tuberculosis is
still an issue in afghanistan i got the
tuberculosis shot and so those are all
vaccines that have been going around
forever and
uh you know every year we're also
mandated to get the flu shot when i was
still in and every time when they gave
me the active culture that's the one
that's like this the mist they kind of
missed it in your nose every time i got
that i was sick and then i would i would
like try to talk to the guy i'd be like
you know like the hm2 the hm3
hey man you know can i get that shot
because you know i really don't want
that missed because i know it's going to
make me sick when i have to call out
again there's like sorry man you can't
do it right but
again these are all vaccines and shots
that have been around for a long time so
i was i was thinking about dan bongino's
show and i'm like isn't it better though
that he's on the networks of these
companies speaking out against it
you know if there are people at these
companies who can't speak out or they're
scared to i'm it's still better that
he's appearing on their radio network at
least giving them some argument more
importantly i was like
if that's going to take away air time
from the radio network
and then result in people working for
danbong genome instead who don't have to
live under that mandate you have more
jobs with no mandate as opposed to the
radio network producing their own shows
and then having the mandate you know
what i mean
so like syndicating a show is better
than them running their own because that
would make more mandate because at least
you have a voice
well well i mean like
let's say let's say are you saying are
you saying take up space yeah yeah yeah
well well listen cumulus says we've got
a 10 p.m slot let's hire this radio
house to do a show for us okay he's got
to be manned it's a it's a mandate for
vaccines for him and all of his staff
now you've got 10 people who are being
faced with the vaccine mandate or they
say why don't we syndicate someone
else's show now those 10 people find a
job with dan banzino with no mandate you
see what i'm saying right so maybe it's
actually better to occupy the space from
these companies so that
it weakens across the board the amount
of people who are under a vaccine
mandate
i really and honestly though i've seen
dan do this like dan's someone who quit
twitter as well so that reminds me of
right so he quit twitter and i believe
it was when he was going to parlor and
so now he'll still do the um the bondino
report on twitter but he won't
personally go on twitter anymore and you
know i just i've seen and i mean i know
dan
um and yeah fox came back so fox came
back on twitter and i you know i know
dan we talk a little bit on the back end
um i think he's a great guy i totally
get it but i know he's taken stands like
this before so it didn't surprise me
when i saw something like that to say
that in his mind it's like i can't
support something morally right if i
have a moral problem with this then i
can't go along with it so i think that's
where he's coming from yeah i mean it's
it's also very easy to fake a lot of
this and to comply and people are just
not doing it based on principles based
on morals we had kyrie irving we have so
many other people we have firefighters
we have police officers we have nurses
we have medical professionals saying hey
this is a big line here and i think
we're witnessing some of the biggest
protests ever especially when it comes
to
how many of them are happening all over
the world how significant they are how
many people are pushing back against a
lot of this and it's just adding a lot
of strangeness to the fact that the
mainstream media doesn't even
acknowledge that there's another side
that there's another debate that there's
a whole bunch of other people standing
up and saying no this is not okay we're
not going to go along with this so um i
mean i mean there there's so many last
couple times last couple times i flew um
you know i just mentioned i was in
denver and
phoenix um
almost at every airport i was going to
there was only one tsa checkpoint
that the whole thing had been wound down
because the labor shortage a lot of tsa
agents are also not complying with
exactly the fox mandate
i think it's over forty percent that
that haven't and doesn't have it yeah
yeah so that's 40 of the workforce
that's a significant workforce of
already you know a big bureaucratic
agency that doesn't do their job well
now they're going to do it a lot worse
well tsa i mean to begin with tsa is
largely theater exactly it's all
security theater it's not
when i was in i can tell you stories
about working at o'hare you know we used
to um
we used to um we would send people in
with like you know for when it was in
the navy and it was all it would all be
you know set up obviously you would get
someone like um you know a dummy ticket
and then you'd give them a device um one
that was designed to appear to be like
an ied and of course this was all set up
under departmental insecurity whatever
media matters and we would send them
through and something like ninety
percent of the time they would go
through higher it was like ninety five
or ninety eight i'm just saying the ones
that i've done so so and then the people
i'd go with would have to sit down with
the tsa agent as they're pulled into
secondary screening and they'd show them
the device and it would be like you know
a bag of doritos and then a soda can
inside of it and then just like all
these electronics and crazy stuff on the
inside they're like you just let this
through i used to work for uh american
eagle airlines this is a long time ago
and back when i was like 18. and
at o'hare
they said if you're driving into the
employee lot you just pull up to a booth
hand them your id card they swipe it
hand it back to you and you drive in
there's no frisk there's no search then
you get out of your car you get on the
bus the bus takes you to the tournament
this is pre or post 911.
this is very much post 911 based yeah
yeah
not that old i wasn't old enough to be
working in the night no no i'm just yeah
i'm just doing the number but um
if you took the train
to work you had to go through security
they said if you're taking the train
through work for if you're taking the
train to work or the bus or you're
getting a ride here you got to go
through normal security like everybody
else and then come down to your zone
room and then i was like
there's there are these doors all over
o'hare that have keypads and as an
employee at the airport you get a card
that you swipe and punch in a code and
it opens these doors okay so when you
want to go from like if you want to eat
food you got to go up to the terminal
you got to go up to where the
restaurants are yeah so you you open the
door when you're coming back to work you
got to swipe your car punch it that lets
you on the runway basically because we
go out on the tarmac and my favorite
thing was i i don't know if they still
do this probably at o'hare where the
baggage uh uh uh conveyors are there's
doors that go right to the back room and
and a lot of people who do uh who work
the ramp that's what's called working
ramp will drop bags off there and some
people work in the back room so i'd be
like so you want me to go upstairs go
through security then go downstairs go
through a similar door into the bedroom
instead of just walking right in the
front door swiping my card and walking
in the back room well well then you
wouldn't be going through security
what's the point of security if this
door is here and anybody can walk
through it you can just walk right
through it technically what and i've uh
what kind of you needed a security card
to walk right through it but what kind
of security or background check would
there be for an employee though
well so i went through a federal
background check i got fingerprinted and
they gave me then they gave me the id
card so
they still want you to go through
standard security which makes no sense
because if you if you own a car you
don't have to do it and that's when you
can actually carry stuff in your car
that's you know what are you gonna carry
you're walking into the airport with
just your backpack but then if you're
downstairs and in the in the baggage
collection area there's a door you just
walk right over to and you swipe it and
you walk right into your workplace but
they they tell you you're not supposed
to do that i'm like dude i don't care
what you think someone is supposed to do
you have no security if that door exists
for employees don't act like you have a
sp like you which employees must go
through security like everybody else no
they don't that's just ridiculous but if
you bring a bottle of water on board oh
they're gonna be on you like white on
rice my favorite thing about the uh the
bottle of water thing is so right they
make you put the water in the containers
right that are all right there so oh
this is too much liquid so you have to
throw on the garbage you sure i'm going
with this so throw it in your garbage so
the next person comes up and they say
that okay now you throw your over three
ounces in the garbage so theoretically
this is all like liquid nitrogen and all
these explosives right so you're
creating right again theoretically wow
an entire yeah you get it an entire
character if you're gonna have a bottle
of liquid nitrogen full of
you know full of explosives that's just
sitting right there
and that that's the way that you guys
consider to no obviously that's not true
i remember one time though i was flying
with a uh with a shotgun that i'd
purchased in arizona i was flying home
with it and you know i called tsa ahead
i'd called the airline ahead and said
hey i'm bringing this it's in the case
it's compliant it's got the locks it's
got everything so i bring it up
and it was american airlines i remember
the
um the check-in you know the check-in
lady was there and she goes well i need
to inspect this i say okay you know i'm
going to unlock it and here's here she
goes all right now you need to take it
out and i look at
her and i'm like
let me just hold on before before i
respond to you let me let me just repeat
what you said you want me to take my
shotgun out right here
in the middle of the airport
i was like ma'am i'm not going to do
that
and then she looks at me and she's like
oh well maybe i could just open it in
the case and take a look at it
yeah maybe you can do that ma'am yeah
let's talk about what's going on with
these uh with chicago man this story is
uh it's getting a little crazy we kind
of derailed a little bit there but uh
but here we go
from nbc chicago some suburban
departments won't send officers to
chicago if needed amid vaccine battle so
we have what is i think it's
5833 in chicago officers out of
something like 12
600 who are either not getting
vaccinated or refusing to disclose or in
complete defiance they may get axed
and lori lifeless like well we don't
need them anyway because we'll find a
way yeah they find a way by calling
suburbs and saying please send us your
cops when they're having trouble now the
suburban department some of them are
like
on your own so this is a good uh
indication to um you know get out of
chicago get out of cities yeah i gotta
say it's gonna be bad in chicago i mean
what are you getting away from like it's
already horrible more children died in
chicago from gang violence than than
covid so so that that should tell you
something and it's already a lawless
place already most of the murders there
go unsolved so less police officers i
mean
they're just getting what they're voting
for so you're seeing this by the way the
same movement now with uh in buckhead
which is the large and very prosperous
uh precinct or district of atlanta where
they're saying they're suing essentially
to divorce themselves from the city and
i went on jesse kelly the other day and
he's a big proponent of national divorce
he says this is what we need it's gonna
happen i said we're not gonna get a
national divorce jesse but we might get
something more along the lines of
national separation right it's like
we're you know we're living in the same
house but you know we're we're sleeping
in different bedrooms we're dating other
people you know but we're staying
together for the sake of the normies and
i think you're going to see that more
and more because if you look at illinois
as a state right it's it's like a bright
red state with the exception of chicago
right you know being it's just dark
blue right
yeah and it's the same with a
large majority of these states um
western maryland by the way has you know
kind of a secession movement where they
want to join up with west virginia
you're seeing this in a lot of different
states particularly western maryland in
western maryland really there's a part
of that we're in western maryland right
now we are yes we are i like this
off the lookout that's actually
something people are talking about so
the idea of breaking away and then
joining other states that are maybe more
conducive to your views uh parts of
virginia are talking about this as well
yeah west virginia i think agreed to
accept or they they said they would
accept the virginia counties if they do
because the problem with virginia is
that it's essentially been annexed
through the blue suburbs of washington
dc and because they're so populated it
just you know the vote wise it just
crosses and of course you've seen the
election it really is the funniest thing
in the world because uh where we are
right now i think you're gonna see it i
think we will see stuff like that we are
about from this house a minute to
virginia and west virginia that's right
no joke literally a minute so we're just
talking about it now that's loud
counting that's laden county right and i
think it's funny when we drive into
virginia for you know groceries or food
and you see gadsden flags everywhere and
i'm like in this state yeah no way dude
deep blue democrat super majority
gadsden flags
yeah i can't believe people stayed in
virginia because i go and i go to some
of these farms and talk to people and
they're like
not
these people understand what's happening
and i'm like why are you in virginia
you know you could literally just move a
block away and freedom is it just they
just don't move cause it's too much of a
hassle well i don't think people care
that gets into i think that gets into
there's still a very genteel
um aristocratic kind of sense with a lot
of virginians a lot of the families that
have been there for a long time like
like we are virginians we are going to
stay in virginia this is what we do this
is who we are we would never leave
right you know regardless of what
happens you know the south should rise
again
you know is it isn't the gadsden flag
like a symbol of virginia like a state
flag or something well no they say the
safe flag of virginia is except for
taranis
it's right right on the flag um and i
say that as a pennsylvanian but um the
gazidim flag is that's more of like a
1776 revolutionary flag right right
right
yeah but but you can get as your license
plate in virginia i'm pretty sure you
can yes dude i was just looking at the
state flag of virginia it's like a roman
dude standing on top of another guy with
a crown on the ground next wild that's
epic so what's six semper tyranus what
does that mean unto tyrants yes it's
basically like the overthrow of the
tyrant it's it's it's what jonathan
when he assassinated abraham lincoln
but he wasn't no he wasn't the
originator of that of that phrase but
supposedly it's it's related to julius
caesar yeah yeah yeah and brutus roman
tyranny mm-hmm brutus
at two
i think we're also seeing a big
population shift i think we're seeing a
lot of people who
were right-wingers leave places like new
york city leave places like chicago
leave places like los angeles because
it's just becoming more and more
restrictive to live there that's why i
think this kind of argument about the
national divorce is starting up because
the lines are being drawn very seriously
where people who don't believe in the
orthodoxy don't believe the narrative
can't live in new york city new york
city just by the way publicly declared
racism a
health emergency god bless you and
they've doubled down
on their vaccine mandates getting rid of
testing uh as a requirement for
new york city employees yeah as an
alternative there's so many black
markets in new york city we have friends
that we have friends of the show they
come on periodically and they're they
live in new york and i'm like you're
crazy there's so many black market vax
cards going around
exactly
that's the big that's the hottest
industry in new york city right now a
postcard he's got to be willing to break
the law to make it which the fbi said
that they're going after and cracking
down on people oh they're probably
saying that they're going to uh be
implementing felonies for people who
fake a fax card
but they also accept foreign vax cards
yeah there's no jurisdiction for so i
guess what what they've said is that if
you use a fake vex card in any capacity
it's fraud right but i don't know if
that actually constitutes fraud it's
it's a
i guess you'd be violating a civil
well there's no law it's a decree and
the plan the penalties on the business
not the person entering the business
and how would they know if a foreign vax
card is real or not unless they've been
to like you know i don't know the
maldives where they issued it or
something well they don't a lot of this
is just made up a lot of businesses are
not complying with it a lot of
businesses aren't even doing it like we
saw with the san francisco story with in
and out but uh new york city really
getting rid of testing for people who
don't want to be vaccinated and are city
employees there's over 300 thousand of
them well that it's it's so ridiculous
because it's it's so anti-science it's
so counter their own narrative because
people who do get the vaccine according
to the cdc can get sick and can transmit
the virus but new york city is just
limiting i don't i just keep i don't
want to keep having an argument about
testing because the real issue is we
shouldn't be mandating people show their
papers nothing yeah of course so there's
a tendency among people to fall into the
left's framing every single time
so they'll be like vaccine mandates and
then everyone starts saying yeah but
what about natural immunity and they go
oh i guess you're right okay mandates
with some exceptions no no mandates i
didn't need my id or a vax card to go
shopping before and i don't think we
should do that now you want to talk
about kids going to public schools with
a conversation about the the research
and the legislation for that no mandates
i don't care what they are what they're
for absolutely agree um but i think it's
also important to counter their
narratives because it's just so
ridiculous and so nonsensical and sadly
there's still some people in the middle
that that are so confused with with the
fear-mongering with the constant
flip-flopping that they don't know what
to make their minds about so i think
clarifying a lot of this nonsense to
them is important
the cops are even in new york you've got
cops that are pissed off you've got fdny
pissed off they're saying you're
violating our union contracts and if
you're in chicago oh you probably
already know how bad the crime can be
now imagine it getting worse suburbs
saying we're not going to help you this
is your problem
you've got cops in seattle walking off
the job turning in their boots yep
turning in their boots and we quit good
for them yeah people saying no contin so
this is why i say this folks enjoy your
leadership get out of cities for at
least i don't know the next five years
maybe more just this is a downward
spiral this is something that i i hear
that schellenberger talked a little bit
about this but didn't talk about some of
the money that um you know that's being
put up behind these people like chester
but in and like krasner a lot of this is
soros money a huge left-wing
institutional money that's going to
support these guys who let's just call
it what it is they're pro-crime they're
allowing crime to be committed in these
cities uh in philadelphia they're
stopping traffic stops just traffic
stops are now not going to be done in
the city of philadelphia
because they claim it's racist new york
city you could shoot up with drugs and
the cops can't do anything so they have
this area in philadelphia called um
kensington and it's they call it the
kensington beach because it's
essentially an open air drug market
where you can go and so many people are
doing drugs there they're shooting up in
public and then kind of like passed out
on the ground it looks like they're you
know guys hunting themselves at the
beach they call it kensington beach and
there's a few there's a few like
instagram accounts and youtubes where
you can go and just see the absolute
depravity and dregs of human society i
saw one video it was a woman with a
newborn baby and still had the umbilical
cord on and she was just lying there on
the ground
wow yeah gosh that's that's your cities
right now in the united states so and
it's only going to get that much worse
it's getting worse i know it feels like
things are bad
this is just the beginning to get worse
people don't get it either man they
don't they really don't like the
washington post they're like maybe
instead of being upset about they're not
being food on the shelves lower your
expectations see that no no there's a
back story to that to that op-ed so that
op-ed i've been told was planted by
kamala harris's press team
because yes yes
to to generate hatred for for herself no
generate hatred towards joe biden oh
so to make his head blow up to make ron
clean and jill biden so this has been my
whole theory of the case and i've been
reporting this uh you know for months
now we just had the leaked audio from
the white house from my insider my
whistleblower came out on this with the
vaccine mandates that
what what one of the big friction points
between the two sides we know kamala
harris and joe biden they were never
friends right it was a shotgun marriage
you know he wanted klobuchar originally
but then
the party basically said you need to
choose kamal harris so they've been
doing everything they can because they
can see and even rasmussen had the story
today uh 54 of voters now believe that
biden is in cognitive decline oh yeah
and
that everyone kind of knows that kamala
harris is the freight train that's
coming forward so jen saki ron klein and
jill biden are doing everything they can
to say you know throw sand on the tracks
and you know
delay the inevitable oh we're going to
give her immigration oh we're going to
give her climate change oh we're going
to give her the border we're going to
give her all this stuff it doesn't
matter because no matter what you try to
do to sag her down
you're not going to help jesus think
about this
i want you to imagine something
in in this reality joe biden is a
fumbling bumbling idiot
he's screwing everything up he's our
youtuber and kamala is coming for him
because this is her chance but now i
want to rewind and present to an
alternate theory an alternate reality
where they all oh by uh uh obama and
biden and hillary and the democratic
establishment sit down and they say this
is gonna be rough for us if we win in
2020 we're gonna have to reverse donald
trump's policies because they helped too
many poor people and we need this
country to be torn and gutted
but people will get mad at us so what do
we do so joe biden says look i'm old
give me one term to reverse trump's
policies and destroy this country and
then i'll take the heat for it and then
what does obama say you don't have to do
this joe remember that quote yes that's
what he really meant
joe was being a hero to the democrats
taking the fall and kamala right now as
the as the washington post was like
madame vice president uh democratic
party we'll do whatever you say do you
want me to press post right now and then
kamalaires is like
do it
and then they press enter and the tier
rolls down and then joe joe walks up
toward her puts hannah charlton says
it's okay
it needs to be this way she's like but
they'll never know what you did for this
country like no i can be that hero yeah
no i don't see it i i think i think kama
harris she
think of it she goes from a staffer to
the mayor of san francisco
to becoming the d.a of san francisco to
becoming the attorney general of
california to becoming the senator of
california
to becoming the vice president and she
will be ladies and gentlemen embrace it
embrace it she will be
the first female president of the united
states selected not elected but but what
i've also been told on this
she wants to pick
another woman to be the vice president
if she picks pelosi so you'll have a
full
female actually i've heard um uh whitner
is the one that she's looking for
all-female
you know because look look when we say
that we all start vomiting like in our
mouths a little bit they're saying the
same thing about trump
they're like trump's gonna run and it's
gonna be trump again he is going right
it's civil war dude you're if you have a
kamala harris trump ticket it's just
like
versus trump right right yeah sorry not
together yeah no no no
no
whitmore ticket i mean that's
just that's it
wow yeah think about that so that i mean
that's that's right that's riley you
gotta be ahead maybe trump just wins in
a landslide at that point i mean yeah if
you look at the polls right now even
like quinnipiac and some of like the
more left lane quinnipiacs died in the
wool blue pole and they're basically
saying that trump would win if you're in
today
so they're going to use as an excuse and
be like biden can't do it biden's going
to be like you know i did my best
and uh
the economy is better than whatever
it'll probably be like
it'll probably be like you know
oh there's a there's a heart issue or
there's something you're not gonna
actually see the 25th amendment but
behind the scenes it'll be like joe i
know that you failed the cognitive test
right i know that you couldn't draw the
clock i know that you couldn't say you
know purple monkey dishwasher and
so you know either you resign or i'm
going to go through this thing and
destroy your legacy i just thought of a
really good idea for a meme because i've
been watching house
you know i'd love to see just like
someone put biden's face over the
patient when he's like true not a shot
with a pressure
and then you have house trying to
diagnose yeah he's like yes
you could rotoscope it yeah yeah you
could be like you know the patient has
ticks
stumbling and falling down the stairs
you know failing to speak properly and
then during speech what is the diagnosis
and then the next scene is the team when
they always have that team scene where
they're like like could it be because
it's
sarcoidosis autoimmune is it autoimmune
it's it's never wait then who's house
though is it it's just houses it's just
him yeah but then you can have like
trump in there i guess and then it's
and then trump comes in he's just like
he's falling apart he's not doing very
well he's not do you guys see this um
this breaking trump news by the way he's
he's announced he's launching a social
media network he saw this yep yep
he's a little too late i would say yeah
a little late to the show oh wait no
hold on a second i've got breaking news
my mom just texted me she says take off
your jacket people are saying your
t-shirt says ip usa no it's just
usa all right mom for you yeah i'm gonna
do it she's down in florida right now
let's talk about let's talk about let's
go back we're talking about soros for a
minute okay oh we got the story from the
daily mail magnificent mile no more
chicago is blighted by shoplifting as
another american city goes down the
toilet because it's left wing ag stops
prosecuting shoplifters who steal less
than one thousand dollars of goods
it's a viral video of people and so the
magma for no chicago is this like strip
of you know just
really nice shops it's like touristy
yeah it's touristy yeah i don't know
michigan avenue yeah michigan and uh
they've got their you know forever 21
and gucci whatever but there's a video
of these people running in and just like
young men stealing a bunch of stuff and
then running out it's very very um it's
very it's so progressive san francisco
it's so progressive i just i just love
the idea
that um seemingly like as if it's
coordinated another city says anything
under a thousand bucks we will not
prosecute what do you think happens when
you're like bro
if you come out you say um ladies and
gentlemen marijuana position is now
decriminalized 30 grams or less or
whatever they did whatever state and
then people are going to be like okay
and they'll go get some and then when
you're like we're also going 36 grams
i'm good decriminalizing
stealing stuff under a thousand bucks
they're gonna be like all right they're
gonna walk in and they're gonna they're
gonna hold their bag and they're gonna
scan every item and it's 991.99
they're going to have a bag of groceries
scan it at the self checkout it'll say
899.99 and they'll go thank you and
they'll walk out without without paying
you good to go and the police officers
don't even want to respond to any of
these calls we were talking about this
with michael what was the name
schallenberger
burger yesterday since he worked with uh
soros of course so so this is something
that soros has been making and he was a
soros guy huge yes yeah a huge a huge
impact on when it comes to setting
policies that directly affect people now
when you look at storefronts that are
affected it's not just the big box
stores it's also middle class it's also
small businesses that are affected here
there's a big conspiracy online saying
that a lot of the big billionaires are
actually financing this so everything
goes digital and and real stores are
kind of thrown and kicked out of
existence and already there was kind of
this retail apocalypse that we were
seeing just a few years ago because of
the internet that started this
apocalypse has been made worse but when
these laws are implemented and stores
are barren because people are just get
gathering their friends coming in there
10 deep 20 deep and just taking whatever
they want
as as long as it's under a thousand
dollars and able to get away with it
what is that going to lead that's going
to lead a lot of these stores not being
open everything to be more digitized so
there's a theory going around that this
is even bigger and that george soros and
other people are involved here in order
to push this retail apocalypse now again
that's a lot of assertions but uh in our
mind nothing and you will be exactly
you'll have no body and you'll be happy
and then you also have a war on cash
that way because when you have a war on
retail you have a war on kind of free
enterprise people being able to exchange
goods with cash anonymously uh instead
of just having everything track traced
in database online wouldn't you want to
be plugged into your own personal matrix
the metaverse excuse me it's called that
mark zuckerberg calls it the matter
version well listen listen you look
outside your window in chicago and what
do you see
crime
gun battles gangs and you say to
yourself i am going to plug into the
oasis mark zuckerberg's metaverse that's
ready player one the oasis right yeah
right yeah see ready player one was
transhumanist propaganda because they
want you to think it'll be like the
oasis oh it'll be this cool video game
and we get to
you know all play and it'll be like all
our favorite games and movies and this
whole john hughes thing i read the book
too i read even
ready player two i like the books but
that's not what it's going to be like
right because it's going to be like
remember he lives in a trailer park this
giant trailer park that's going to the
stacks that's going to be the whole
world they kill his family they kill his
mom
yeah they crush her and so and there's
like there's like this corporate drone
strike that like takes her out and his
entire neighborhood that's gonna be the
world and then you're not gonna be
someone who has like a physical
you know uh self other than some like
corpulent
ball of goo
right you're going to be like in wali
right now
sure and the real like have you seen
surrogates yeah so it's for those
familiar circuits of the movie where
everyone has a robot version of
themselves but like in the beginning
this like two people uh mean it's like a
hot chick and a guy and then they try to
track they get murdered because this
device can kill them through the
surrogate circuits are basically robots
that you you control from your house for
safety reasons and then they track this
guy the the woman down turns out it's a
big morbidly obese man right using a
woman body so a lot of this people think
they're going to live in this digital
virtual world where they will be
what you know whatever their whatever
self-identified person is or you know
but if you actually think about it
whenever it comes to
these authoritarian ideologies
the low the low-ranking individuals who
foment it by you know protesting or
rioting or demanding it think there's
going to be some beautiful new world
it's going to be we're going to have all
this free stuff i love that meme right
where the guy said what do you what are
you going to do once communism is
established and then he's like i'll
probably take some art classes hang out
with my friends do some farm classes on
my farm and then maybe go to the store
and then someone's like you're fine
hilarious these people don't get it
hilarious no i actually saw a good one
like black i saw a twist on that
actually recently
where they were saying it no no
it was one where they were saying uh uh
so what do you want to do in the new
world and it was like a woman they go oh
well you know just like kind of raise my
family take care of my kids maybe do
some gardening you know sort of hang out
read write write some poetry and they
said so you want to be a trad wife yeah
yeah
they're like your kids yeah your kids
our kids
i saw a similar meme of an npc being
like during communism i'm going to write
poetry and study
uh and and practice my slam poetry and
then uh it's another npc with a machine
gun in the next frame saying off to the
glue
no no the better one is it's a cry it's
a guy with glasses and like a hipster
haircut and it's green and he's crying
and he said there must be some mistake
i'm i'm a web blogger i should be
writing stories and the guy pointing the
gun says shut up and break the rocks
that's the future there must be some
mistake i supported all of this
there's a reason we don't talk about the
mensheviks anymore to be fair though if
they do this metaverse thing where they
want you to spend most of your life in a
digital world controlled by mark
zuckerberg sure they're the the problem
isn't going to it's gonna be brave new
world it's not gonna be this like it's
not gonna be a digital gulag it's going
to be a digital pleasure powers yeah
exactly yeah they're gonna they're gonna
be giving you all the great things you
want and if you defy them they take
those things away from you you'll be
getting paid to eat digital food instead
of real food like if you're hungry
they'll be like eat this digital
broccoli for a token and then you'll do
it
you'll skip a meal because it'll be hard
to get food to people so that this will
be ways to if they can if they can do
true and more
what and then you get like a dose of
nutrients in the real world
like injectable nutrient paste or
something i just picked up an msn a
business insider article jack dorsey
mocks zuckerberg's metaverse plan saying
it's dystopian
oh really
i think jack's more legit than people
give him credit for but he's not in a
position but that's my point
billionaire oh yeah that he just how
much money did he give away to like
social justice causes spare me dude's a
coward i mean regarding twitter he's not
a position with twitter to do anything
with twitter anymore he sold the company
basically yeah but he could buy up large
portions of it back he's got square and
he's working with bitcoin he doesn't
care dude you know i haven't heard he
could get in the fight i have unknown
from him he's speaking out no no no no
no no zuckerberg's uh i don't know i've
heard so much from this guy about what
he was planning to do for the past
several years he never does well some of
you do and what happens is he says i'm
gonna make a social media platform
that's crypto based on the blockchain so
you can't ban people and then he does
nothing but when he says it everyone's
like oh look at jack dorsey so now he
comes out and he's like mark
zuckerberg's dystopian and people are
like oh oh yeah jack dorsey shop he's
not doing this see this is how i feel
about john stewart that's exactly well
i think i agree with you by the way i
feel the same way about elon musk
gino is threatening to walk away from
his entire syndicated well it's just
words i mean we're all talking about
people just talking right now i still
think steve bannon's not steve bannon
was like shove it and they're like we're
gonna arrest you
let me let me let me and i'll you know
just because i've actually read the
um the legal filings from bannon's
lawyers and from his team and like he
and i haven't discussed this or anything
even though you know i you know i
co-host on war room a lot um so i've had
like ton of people hitting me up oh
what's even going to do with you know
it's right there in the file links he's
pointed out that he did testify for in
front of mueller he did go to the senate
he did go to the house he's testified
three separate occasions and he actually
says that he'd be happy to testify again
but the floor vote's not gonna they
wanna ask him about well this is the
legal side he wants to they want to ask
him about his conversations with trump
and the thing is
when he had those conversations with
trump this is prior to january 20th that
means trump was the sitting president of
the united states executive party that's
under executive privilege this the house
which is part of congress is part of the
legislative branch and it's and the
supreme court has held this for a long
time that those branches that this is a
check against right yeah but jack laws
don't matter when no no no you run an
empire look what they did to michael
flynn look what they did to so many
other people that stood in their way
they took them down i still believe
dorsey and zuckerberg are just front
people in my personal opinion a part of
the larger kind of agenda that they're
pushing well the larger agenda is esgs
from blackrock and then essentially
giving an esg is a corporate social
credit score so blackrock has the money
because they've been given these loans
they can get it directly from the fed
through the cantillian effect right
you're getting their get they're not
seeing the inflation on their end but
then if anybody else wants the
investment if anybody else wants to
boost their stocks through blackrock
buying whatever percentage they're
buying of you you know do they have
seven percent of pfizer today four
percent of fiverr say it fluctuates um i
was actually talking to a guy about this
and he would he owns a utilities company
in pennsylvania and he was saying like
blackrock has been buying and selling
our stock for years and they won't even
talk to us like we've tried to reach out
to them and they won't even get on the
phone with us and they'll be spending
millions and millions of dollars because
of this and
when they go into it they'll say what
what's what's the purpose we have no
idea but now when you see larry fink and
the rest of them pushing these esgs it's
essentially you've got a bunch of wall
street boomers that are saying oh we've
got nine trillion dollars in assets as a
money management firm so how do we then
impose our vision of this utopia on
everybody else well they come up with
these esgs and if you want access to
that capital you've got to go along with
your corporate social credit score
what's esg mean environmental social
governance
what is it exactly it's a corporate
social credit score so it's the idea
it's a score that even zuckerberg is
going to be under so even twitter is
going to be under that if you it's it's
basically it's literally like a
corporate social credit card social
credit scores and it's and it's i'm
happy you brought this up because i
remember researching this a little bit
and then fully understanding that yes
and all the great the great reset but
it's also the woke agenda it it explains
why so many so many of these same
policies are kind of brought out in
unison by all these very powerful forces
all at once and they kind of doubled
down on them but that's why we see the
pope literally work with mastercard and
visa and meet with them in order to push
for the great reset in order to try to
implement it as fast as they can and
again they outline everything they're
doing it's in their own documents it's
on their website they brag about it the
world economic forum literally makes
very clear about super futuristic videos
about how glorious everything's going to
be how fun everything's going to be how
convenient and better everything's going
to be when you know you just you just
give up those pesky rights you just give
up those pesky civil liberties or your
freedoms and liberties
yes of course yeah that was uh here
here's the most important takeaway
though they're doing a new kingsman
right yeah the third one yeah it's a
prequel though right i think in the
movie kingsman a tech billionaire is
trying to figure out how to stop global
warming by having the poor people all
purge themselves and he gives the elites
a device to protect them but the most
important takeaway from that film is
that the leader of kingsmen is in on it
right so when you get the pope coming
out like the the leaders are all like
agreeing about this listen i actually
pulled this out before i came out today
world economic forum 2016
from the global future councils
welcome to the year 2030. welcome to my
city or should i say our city
i don't own anything i don't own a car i
don't own a house i don't own any
appliances or
clothes
it might seem odd to you but it makes
perfect sense for us in this city
everything you considered a product has
now become a service that's most common
so like when you wake up a guy clothes
you or wow no it's like so borrowing no
it's like you rent you'll rent clothes
like the way you write a talks or
there's like rent the one way it's it's
already started right what about
retirement
and then you have them for like a week
you wear the clothes then you put them
back to the service then you get the
next one and if you say i hate the
government they take your clothes away
yeah you exactly yeah they shut off your
ability to be able to buy stuff to be
able to go do you want to over market if
you want to open your smartphone are
they going to like try and electrically
shock brains to pacify people is that
what well
i haven't read anything about that in
the world economic forum documents and
what they kind of strive to achieve but
everything's out there on their website
they did delete that one famous article
where they said you will own nothing you
will have no privacy and you will be
happier than ever they deleted that so
you have to actually go and did they try
to say like oh no this was a submission
into a thing and it wasn't like your
logo is on the video
but they're literally talking about
controlling so many aspects of your
existence i mean bill gates is right
literally this is the clear yeah yeah
bill gates is of course on board with
this he's working and financing
technology that will literally have
implantable microchips that will control
if you could have children with an on
and off button yes look up bill gates
microchips funding in a way that could
control your fertility on and off
through electricity so so they're
working on control i don't believe you i
don't care what's that right about the
fertility chip yes yes if no this is a
false claim from reuters
no that was all the false claim was
about coronavirus yes so so some people
are conflating this with coronaviruses
it has nothing to do with coronavirus
what is this what is this this is what
i'm talking about this is what bill
gates is financing he's literally
financing a and uh
it's a birth control yeah exactly
pregnancy track people no hold on hold
on hold on i got no problem with you
saying that bill gates wants to create a
chip that can turn off fertility exactly
but as long as you you give us the full
framing of it yes bill gates is working
on what they say is a pregnancy tracking
app and uh well i don't know what this
website is glass room and fertility
activity they say some invasive blah
blah that the general idea is that women
would be able to have birth control or
something no not just that it's about
controlling fertility with an on and off
button that someone else will control so
this is another layer remote control
contraceptive chip available
yes thank you thank you thank you uh all
right the articles in 2014.
right from 2014 they say the chip isn't
implanted under a woman's skin releasing
a small dose of leaven or gestural a
hormone birth control this will happen
every day for 16 years but can be
stopped at any time by using a wireless
remote control the project has been
backed by bill gates there's a big
difference between some a woman wanting
birth control and being like i can turn
it off when i decide to have a kid
and bill gates financing this yeah it
doesn't say that you can turn it on all
i'm saying is bill gates is financing
this and bill gates is all along with
this great economic you know the great
reset he's going along with this agenda
and he's creating technological uh
evolutions we're talking about literally
uh vr so what makes you think that this
is not going to be a part they're gonna
force you to not be able to have kids
when in reality people choosing not to
have kids
yes and no on certain levels because if
they're controlling your existence
through vr what makes you think that
they won't move into another step i mean
this is technology that china would have
loved to have a few years ago that they
would have implemented right away so
when we're talking about vr headsets and
controlling our reality
by the way this is this is another layer
to it that people need to understand
because there is a large portion of
people pushing this that do talk about
the need of reducing the world
population of getting rid of of people
because they pollute and we have to have
climate change effective green policies
that get rid of people so when you have
bill gates being able to create a
technology that could turn people's
fertility on and off you know that
switch that power is something that we
should be talking about especially when
it comes to you know theorizing i'm not
saying this is going to happen directly
but i'm saying the technology is being
built their plans are kind of out there
in their own websites on their own
documents they're talking about it
themselves so when they're implementing
a lot of this you should be concerned
and you should raise questions that's
all i'm saying
i'm not saying i have a pr i have a
prophecy of what's going to happen here
because no one does that that reminds
your story so when i lived in china
i was visiting
it was a friend of mine who had
basically an uncle that lived out in the
countryside from shanghai
and in the county where he lived he had
one of the largest factories and he ran
it and ran it very well
it was a toy factory and because he ran
it so well
the uh the county party chairman wanted
to reward him and as a reward he was
allowed to have a second child yes so
and i remember meeting
you know and this was just you know my
my friend's uncle and his two kids and i
remember just hanging out with the
family and we're just you know playing
around doing whatever but then sitting
there thinking that this
human being
this person that i'm like just you know
rolling the ball back and forth with
they exist because the chinese communist
party decided that due to your loyalty
and your legal service to the party and
to the country that you can be allowed
to create an extra life exactly and had
he not by the way
they would have taken it away and the
same globalist that that implemented and
inspired and put into place the child
the chinese one child policy that
implemented that everything that has
china become are the same people or the
same minds or the same quote
intellectuals behind the world
economically my theory of the case as
well exactly the world economic forum
and the great reset are america and the
west's answer to
to live like like people are living in
china right now
and they're going to bring layers to
this that are mind-boggling and at first
people think you're crazy when you bring
up what they could potentially do to you
but but when they have the technology
when they're building this we have to
start asking but
here's the difference the difference is
in the west because we have a tradition
of personal choice that they don't have
in the east there will be it won't
necessarily be that they can control the
remote they'll tell but they'll sit
there and say oh you should do this
it'll be better for the country it'd be
better for the environment better for
the planet better for the future
this is the anti-natalist movement or a
cancel culture right will come up so all
of these various
propaganda campaigns will be pushed
throughout society um you'll see
propaganda movies you'll see propaganda
netflix you'll see propaganda tv shows
all talking about pushing these issues
that go along well it's a combination
it's like brave new world that they do
it through
pleasure and 1984 it's a combination of
both worlds coming together yesterday i
said it was like revenge of the nerds
and 1984. but in reality when you look
at the techniques that they're using to
pacify the general public a lot of them
and there's also a part of it it's the
carrot and the stick and that's how they
are going to implement a lot i know
exactly what to say to bring up what
luke is talking about because it's
through the lens of something that we're
seeing every day
look at what they're saying about the
unvaccinated look at the way they're
saying that unvaccinated people should
not be given priority in hospitals
now what happens if unvaccinated people
go to the hospital and they say oh i
need a c-section i'm having a problem
with my pregnancy i need an emergency
c-section oh but you're unvaccinated
yep right
what happens then yeah there's well well
ma'am you're if we continue down social
credit score is actually quite
impressive but your baby is registering
a zero and we can't help the baby if
that's the case it's already happening
in italy there's a lot of guys
we were talking about the video
yesterday there's people being denied
medical services there's people being
denied organ transplants in the united
states because
let's be honest here they don't have the
right social credit score paper please
uh approval system by the federal
government and and when we're living in
a society that's already this
divisive disdiscriminatory where they're
saying die unless do what the government
wants you to do i mean this is a level
that it's it's very hard to go back from
luke you just go to the government
website you don't even have to think you
don't even have to think exactly that's
that's that's that's the thinking that's
going to lead us down to living like the
average person in china right now i
think one of the things that concerns me
about the remote control contraceptive
chip that they're talking about is that
it's always on so if a woman gets it in
her body at the age of 14 it's always on
and the remote control turns it off but
if the remote control malfunctions she's
it's always on and she can no longer
have kids women who's controlling the
remote control like what percentage of
women are being medicated with hormonal
treatments at a young age already huge a
large number huge yes and we're start
you're starting now to by the way see
the pushback against this because people
are talking about the absolutely
horrific uh side effects of birth
control and what it does to women um
i mean
it used to be a punch line hillary
clinton attacked breitbart for talking
about this during the during the
election but and i think they were just
a little bit ahead of the curve and not
everybody's talking about this yeah i
used to think birth control whatever now
it's like i respect a woman that doesn't
want to use it yeah
i i think people need to realize that
it's a it's a hormonal treatment it's
going to change the way you think
exactly
yes i remember reading a story where
they said that women who are about to
get married should get off birth control
for six weeks and then uh check to see
if they enjoy the smell of their fiance
yeah because what was happening was a
lot i remember that yeah women would be
on birth control they'd be like i'm
going to marry this guy then as soon as
they got married okay let's have a kid
get off birth control and she'd be like
whoa he smells really bad and i don't
want to have kids with him it's like
yeah because the hormonal treatments
iran was changing i'm going to keep
going on this alex jones track plus the
birth control can't be filtered out and
is passed on to a lot of people
unknowingly
bill gates is going to get there
the bumblebees are going to be involved
here
hold on are you saying that these female
hormones from the birth control are
going in the water where there are frogs
yes yes thank you we did it and we
did it
but but but it but it's true it's having
a turn of the freaking frogs exactly
it's having a nuclear
neurological effect on so many different
people
and what are the effects well you could
see record low uh record uh infertility
uh we see europe is going down you'll be
infertile and you'll be happy exactly
well there's a big component to this
with limiting uh human growth limiting
people having the ability to have their
own children so there is there's a lot
of the biggest there's so many things
you know i see with this and and you
know like you know people say like oh
jack how'd you go i'm sorry like no i i
mean i was raised catholic my whole
family is catholic both sides all the
way back you know that's how we look at
things and the more and more this is one
of the dangers of transhumanism and joe
allen out there is a great guy who
writes on this you know one of the
biggest dangers of that is that the more
and more you
uh cyber size yourself the more and more
you give yourself your autonomy your
physical self over to your neurological
self over to these machines right the
more you hook yourself up to these
machines to become like a darth vader
type creature then you're cutting
yourself off from any type of spiritual
life you're cutting yourself off from
any kind of transcendent
experiences that you could be having
through prayer through meditation um if
you're more on the secular side but you
know you are not going to be able to do
that why because your own thoughts are
going to be controlled by these
mechanisms there's a reason they go
after your pineal gland i could continue
on this track
i pulled up the story from npr and what
they actually say is there's some other
stories saying that the estrogen in the
water is actually less than one percent
is from improperly disposed of
medications what they what npr does say
though is plastics leech bpa yeah into
your water
and it is an estrogenic chemical so it
mimics estrogen don't touch your seeds
so if you're drinking we got these
beautiful glass bottles here this is tim
cast pure this was fantastic i just
finished that double nine stage filter
that's that's that's water right there
baby bias phenol a not all plastic has
it in it but a lot of it did until
recently stay away from seed oils don't
trust or does it don't touch receipts
because of the material receipts i heard
about that too that also wrecked your
testimony
my brother talks about so there's the
soy boy thing get it away from me cbs a
lot of conservatives were like the these
these hipsters are eating so much soy
it's making them effeminate and
uh so my brother was talking about this
he was like yeah but soy is a
phytoestrogen it's a weaker form of
estrogen so actually the natural
estrogens in your body would be
displaced yeah we started both we
started talking about it and i think
what we actually
actually ended up saying was hold on a
minute
if a dude is getting a small amount of
estrogen that's potent but then gets a
massive flood of less potent estrogen
but still more of it it will have an
estrogenic effect on the man feminizing
him and for women
who are getting a larger amount of
stronger estrogen they're now having
that blocked by phytoestrogens displaced
so it's effectively androgynizing men
and women hey speaking of we just got
glass bottles you know in all
seriousness i know huge i mentioned my
mom's watching but huge shout out by the
way to um to my grandmother passed away
in 2012 but she was talking about all
this stuff in the 1990s good for her she
was so far ahead of the curve literally
all the things we just discussed
and you know it used to be one of those
things like okay grandma whatever
and she would go to there wasn't whole
foods at the time but she would go and
she would get organic and she would put
things in tupperware and bring her own
food everywhere she's like i don't want
chemicals i want real food i want
anything messing with that stuff i don't
want the estrogen that's in everything i
don't want the estrogen that's in the
meat by the way because of what they
give factory processed um animals and
she was 100 right about so much of this
stuff a hundred percent right everybody
talks about it now cutting edge and she
actually wrote something
uh before she passed away that i
recreate years ago i recorded like as an
audiobook just to you know she would
give it out at her church and stuff to
people and i was i keep wondering like
will i be incredibly sued by the ftc if
i just go back and re-release that thing
you know we have so many farms around
here
we uh we took a ride we stopped at this
little uh little farm stand and the
gentleman there was selling fresh
tenderloins from a neighboring farm and
it was clean grass-fed right there in
the spot and he was like you could eat
it raw it's clean meat
and we uh we cooked it up pretty uh
medium rare
amazing you don't know what you're
getting when you go to these
supermarkets and you're getting corn fed
beef and you're getting salmon they die
or you know reddish orange because
they're actually gray fish farms
every single one of my grandparents had
a joke and in polish that means just a
plot of land uh that you could farm on
so they would always farm their own food
because in poland a lot of the buildings
it's not big it's like a yeah it's a
small plot but you
you grow your own vegetables you have a
little farm that's dedicated to you and
there's these little plots outside of
these major buildings uh because
communists it just had this kind of
brutalist architecture where they had
these huge
buildings where everyone was just
crammed into and when whenever there was
room they would create these little
plots where people would grow their own
food because during communism there's
not a lot of food so every single one of
my grandparents uh made sure when we
always made their own food when we were
visiting sort of the you know the
posobic um hometown back in
in poland it's near uh it's like an hour
outside of uh krakow and it's near jejo
if you know where that is like i know i
know kind of kind of towards levi's like
towards the border um the valve i should
say for my polish friends out there that
you know you would just you wake up and
you go around town and it's like okay
you know across the street bob's got the
chickens let me get some eggs then you
go down here all right so fish
people in open markets selling their
butcher
markets yeah we'll go down yeah no not
markets but uh technically black markets
there's people saying that wet markets
look like like the animals there's no
things definitely not
black
then you go across the bridge and then
the cousins are there with the cows and
you get fresh milk and then you just go
do that once in the morning and then
that's the food that you eat for the day
and there wasn't this
you know this sort of like very western
modernist idea of i'm gonna go to the
supermarket and then stock up on stuff
for like a week or two weeks you know
the cost coefficient of everything yeah
just you go and there's no such thing as
farm to table because that's just food
yeah like there's no difference do you
speak polish no not at all okay i mean
like
let's get it
you know it's funny though uh once china
takes mandarin right who's going to be
better off that was awesome so i will be
able to what i'm going to do is my job
in the gulags will be to teach the
mandarin classes to all of you so that
we will be able to communicate with the
guard yeah luke you speak polish but
how's that going to help us when the
communists take over
i don't think i'm going to be around
when that happens
out
you know i love chinese culture i used
to read that accent romance of the three
kingdoms was like a childhood treasure
to me and the heroes lobe you read the
book yeah oh wow wow yeah play the video
games and everything and it's i i'm
still confused like i know the republic
of china went to taiwan fled the
government fled basically and now than
the ccp but cpc i'm being told and like
there there's so much i want peace
between nations but i also understand
like appeasement like neville
chamberlain appeased hitler gave him the
su dayton land and then hitler invaded
poland it's like should we have appeased
hitler in the early days it wasn't like
that it was russia and germany that yeah
and then invaded poland they made a pact
from the from the left and the right so
september 1st was germany september 17th
1939 was russia yeah and the polish
people said screw it we're still going
to fight both of you even though we're
going to lose we're still going to fight
if there's any diplomatic route between
the chinese people and the american
people i i'm always well there certainly
is
in so the chinese people you'd say la
bashing which is known as it's the old
hundred names because you know that's
sort of like the hundred surnames of
china and there's a difference between
the la bashing and the party so the
party's the ccp and if you actually
calculate the numbers you know we always
say the one percent in the u.s it's
actually less than one percent of the
1.4 billion population of china is a
member of the party so being a member of
the party what they'll do is they co-opt
right so as you're on your way up uh
china it's a very mer it's a very
meritorious society so if you're doing
well in school if you're doing well in
business if you're seen as someone who's
notable in any one of these fields what
they'll do is at some point the party
comes up to you and offers you
membership and then being a member of
the party becomes your way to gain
access to greater capital to greater
funds to greater networking so in that
way they're able to maintain control
over all these industries but then of
course they've also got eyesight into
what exactly you're doing so every
you know prior to social media and
technological surveillance right they
would just assign somebody they'd assign
a guy so you'd have a minder for your
work every work unit would have a party
member every apartment block would have
a party member and then they would be
keeping track who's getting married
who's having kids uh who's getting
divorced who died who you know who's
moving who's going here and there so
they have this mass surveillance network
within the country writ large they don't
even need the technology for that and
that still continues to this day the la
baijing are like old family names the
old families yeah like the lou family
the the shoe family like just those
names you hear xu uh l-i-u yeah so it's
it's like saying the hoi polloi or
saying you know the the proletariat or
the deplorables you know in the us it's
just saying like the the little guys are
they is they're like against the cp ccp
they're underneath they're underneath
the ccp do they do the last name first
in china they do so like xi jinping she
would be the family name oh okay so his
actual name is people refer to him as
she so chairman g right but his name is
actually shin ping jinping jinping yeah
so he's given i mean you wouldn't they
don't really
you know you don't really address
somebody by their first name like the
way we do in the u.s unless you're with
other members of their families yeah
it's like it's very familiar to do that
like i i wouldn't do that and there's
like another back in my neighborhood i
just wrote people by their last names
too yeah yeah isn't there like you give
people like a common like a common name
if you know them pretty well like kong
ming would be choking
uh they called them kong ming right
people that know why what kind of names
is a little bit different because
is his last name but it's very very rare
to have a double syllable last name in
china but he actually had one that guy
was smart huh very smart very story of
him sitting on the on the wall playing
the loot with the doors open can you
tell the story do you know it i don't
know the whole story off the top of my
head but yeah he was uh general they
were basically outnumbered and being
invaded by i don't remember who xiao dun
i hope is the person that was doing i
don't remember some some general under
south south i think was coming to invade
the city and
they just opened the gates and uh
went up and sat there and played his uh
what was it a loot he played
and they came there and they saw him and
they were like uh this is a trap
right so they turned this huge army and
they yeah they retreated
the door he opened the gates and he set
up on the wall just playing and they
were like no
all right
we have to you know it's like it reminds
me of uh um the dude from uh who is the
guy in princess bride
uh who was right wesley no the smart guy
not pheasant oh
i can't remember what's the name
no no the smart guy who was like
inconceivable that's wallace sean what's
the characters now i don't know let's
find out how could i not remember
i thought was his name no that's the
giant that's the giant okay yeah
was that it yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah so this reminds me of like when it
is where it actually worked out
you know when when when chico liang sits
on the wall and right right it's like
i know that you know that i know yeah
exactly and he ends up winning out he
was constantly and with this guy c mcgee
you know is that how you pronounce his
name south south advisor and there was
this constant like battle of checkers
between the two of them or chess
throughout the years it was it's an
incredible in the three kingdoms is
incredible yeah that's actually salto is
actually they you've um you know we have
the phrase in english of um you know
speak of the devil and he shall appear
well in chinese they have ishmael
so it's like actually like a similar you
know if you speak of south south shall
appear that's wild because it's like the
hero in the story i don't want to i mean
it's hard to spoil a 600 year old novel
but
basically the heroes in my opinion lose
they don't succeed which is the sad part
it's like a tragic history
but it's just a beautiful story of
brotherhood someone actually said ian
luke and tim you're like lube guan you
and jang fei i'm like these are like
what did you just call me
i'm not sure which one you are maybe
guan you i'm not sure
it's but it's like the three heroes
basically that are up against all odds
i love that do you ever read uh journey
the west no that one's great too the
monkey king oh so you got that's that's
the next one that's your homework next
time you've come back
i want to see it
thank you
fezig was the giant buzzing was giant
okay that was that was andre the giant
yep and then vasini was they're remaking
it yeah oh no no
no see my favorite thing about princess
bride is that it like it's actually kind
of low budget when you think of it like
when they're on that that night scene at
sea you can tell it's like like a pool
like an indoor pool that's just like the
lights turned off but i like that i like
that ass and the you know the rats of
unusual size or like rodents of usual
size they're just like like obviously
like really really poorly made puppets
what's the hero the west this novel
you're talking about monkey king monkey
king uh-huh what's what's that about
uh it's it's kind of like they steal a
giant gorilla and bring him to new york
and he climbs a building oh so you've
read it
one of the suicide it's this idea that
you know
going to the west and and going to the
western china of course is like going
out to the desert but that you sort of
like you you find yourself you find
you're faced with your own fears you're
faced with your own foibles your own
shortcomings as a person but then to
seek wisdom you need to face yourself
cool yeah so these are considered some
of the cl and the other ones dream of
red chambers so these are considered the
three great classics of china you know
the movie hero
apparently there was a controversy
around that's it's a jet li and he's
trying to preserve the word or something
well so jeff was banned in china though
well so no no no hero no no no hero was
like funded by the ccp oh really yeah no
hero is a super pro ccp um
uh movie and i'll spoil the heck out of
that one so in hiro
it's kind of like star wars right so
you've got an empire and you've got
rebels it's just ancient china instead
of the future or excuse me a long time
ago galaxy far far away but with the
difference being that at the end luke
skywalker decides to murder his friends
and join the emperor
um and basically you're told that's sort
of like the you know the great dane iman
of the film at the climax when he's
about to kill the emperor the emperor
says don't you understand the only way
that china can survive is if we have an
empire and so the emperor must win you
must turn your back on the rebels and he
said and then gently becomes a hero by
turning his back on his friends i gotta
say it would be really awesome if you
know at the end of the return of the
jedi
vader's like join the dark side and luke
is like all right yes yeah and or if he
was like don't you see what will happen
the war will wars will break out the
fighting everything you've witnessed and
luke is like he's right
people are just bad and then he joins
the emperor and then he just starts he
like then you see luke wearing the dark
cloak and he goes up to han and he's
like hey what happened
just walked up the layout cuts her head
off that would have been way better than
whatever it is they made after these
seriously i don't even know
after those
they don't exist my issues with with
chinese
lore is the is the empire of it like
even lube who's one of my heroes of all
time was there to restore the emperor
well see this is the thing right china
has always been a series of empires and
this goes back to confucianism which is
it's it's hierarchical
it's you know the father you know the
children must give
homage to the father the father must
give homage to the local leader the
local leader must give homage to the
regional leader the provincial leader
and then eventually all the way up to
the empire so this has been the way the
ccp structured itself is actually very
traditional in chinese society in in
certain ways when you look at it in
terms of this hierarchy and many people
looked at this and said that china is
essentially just the ccp is just the
latest dynasty it's not necessarily as
familial as the former dynasties were
but it's a dynasty in many aspects
let's go to super chats let's do it you
haven't already smash that like button
go to timcast.com become a member we're
gonna have a bonus members only segment
but we also have a massive library of
content you can check out really great
conversations there over at temcast.com
let's read what we got and also we're
having an event this saturday in the
harpers ferry area is
the tickets were free for members who
are at 25 bucks or more those are all
gone we're auctioning off two tickets at
a time so we just closed our first
auction our new our next auction is up
and live any member can bid if you'd
like to and there are eight remaining
tickets so definitely check that out at
timecast.com
all right michael fernando mello says i
refuse to show proof of vaccination and
will not bend the need to silicon valley
authoritarianism shout out to the bay
area mises caucus we love freedom rock
on tim cass see y'all this saturday very
excited very cool i have no idea what
i'm going to do on saturday either
because my plan was like just play pool
like you know hang out you know it's
like we have like a bar
and
you know i don't know but i guess i'm
gonna have to say something oh i have a
correction in by the way i have a
correction this is this is from mom
again grandmom always used glass
containers never tupperware oh
nevertheless
very smart all right gerald armstrong
says jack i'm a retired navy vet and i'm
going to school for international
politics national security option at
penn state i'm interested in the intel
community can you be a mentor for me we
are um i mean if look i'll put it this
way you know joining the it's the intel
community is definitely not jack bauer
it's not james bond it's you know
wokeness and pronouns and everything
else um that being said i do think
patriots need to go into the ic because
we need to retake these institutions
from the inside out so yeah reach out to
me
shoot me an email we'll we'll get in
touch
right on all right let's see
jake
angovine says
iraq and afghanistan vet here trying to
get a little spotlight and an issue near
to me k1 fiance visas are not being
processed it's been two years since i've
seen my fiance wow
this hashtag love is not tourism
great reset they don't want people
traveling so i don't know it's weird
right it's all no no traveling until
you've you know you've gotten your your
social credit score up up to where we
need it just tell them to go through the
southern border
yeah all right medic knight says tim ask
jack what he thinks of dave smith and
the libertarian party mises caucus
so i've you know i've
referred to the libertarians as lo
albertarians for many years um i've also
said may god strike me down if i ever
refer to myself as a classic liberal but
you know the mises cause is it myself
mises okay um i've seen some interesting
things from them and we've we've
communicated on the uh on the back end a
little bit so i'm i'm pleasantly
intrigued by the mises caucus i think
they're great um namely because
michael malus press secretary
oh wow yes you know
i think about waking up in the morning
working every day i wake up around 7am
and i start reading the news and there
is just something about
taking a day off
order in some pizza i haven't eaten any
pizza bread or anything like that but i
would in this instance some wings
turning the tv on to watch michael malus
give a press briefing and then just
relax it'd be the most satisfying thing
to watch just him just tearing apart the
press
it'd be great it would be incredible to
have an anarchist in the government
worth it just for that i mean
you know particularly michael because
he's smart well ready he's going to talk
circles around these break down like put
sunset clauses on laws less government
for more benefit
oh hey check this out i i did notice
this patrick siegfried says tim one of
the two counter protesters at the
netflix protest with the we like dave
sign was dick masterson don't you know
the guy i never met him i did go on his
show we had like a funny uh internet
beef or something and then i went on a
show and you know everything's cool but
uh i did notice that you guys know dick
masterson no he's like a comedy podcast
the name rings about so it was so he
wasn't really there
supporting dave he was just kind of like
doing a bit i was promoting but he was
okay i'm i'd assume so uh he was he had
a sign that said like we like jokes and
i saw the video and i thought that was
him i was like oh hey but you know in
the video of the guy getting attacked it
was just decriminalized jokes
i ca i can't believe how insane that is
decriminalized you could show up not
even this is this is the clever thing
like these guys this guy wasn't
protesting he was like i like dave and
they attacked him
no dave chappelle should have gone
you know
i don't know man i want to go find like
the next time i'm speaking somewhere and
there's going to take a big protest like
i want to go out and like join the
protest and be like
should be canceled get that guy off
stage that's um uh kevin smith did that
he protested
yeah that was smart yeah all right doug
kaplan says tim i watched your video
earlier today and i think i get it when
you explain about sleeping on the couch
i get some kind of phenomenon in my
well-being i
feel i should help put transporting
materials like on barges and with mixed
martial arts i really don't know how to
explain this drive but i pray for
everyone's strength and courage to you
all so just to clarify the context there
the point i often make is that when i
was working for vice i was sleeping on a
couch
uh vice was paying me moderately okay
and i said i want to save all this money
and so i slept on my friend's couch
instead and then eventually i said okay
i'll get an apartment for a little bit
more and then i had money saved up to do
what i wanted to do when i wanted to do
it a lot of people aren't willing to
save money like that they're like well
no no i'm going to get everything they
want to be comfortable yeah i did that
listen listen to dave ramsey don't you
know if you if you're someone who's out
there living debt to debt or if you use
you know i know people who you know and
this is what they want they want you to
be in debt they want you to be serfs
they want you to be irvine urban serfs
gig slaves essentially when you have
your oh but amazon comes immediately
ubereats comes immediately right but you
have no wealth they don't want you to
generate wealth they want you to say oh
look this is cheaper i'm going to go
with this because i don't have any money
saved spend spend spend don't own any
clothes don't underneath you know don't
even own any food if they can find a way
luke if they can find a way that
microchip is going to be inside of you
the microchip for your food
we got a big super tip that just came in
but i want to read it because um this is
cool evan hogan says yeah going to have
to give you guys at least a grand a
month i would give you more if it seemed
like you needed it tails from the
inverted world hit a note with me
reminded me of sean kennedy evan massive
super chat seriously thank you so much
and i'm reading it because we are really
trying to do more than just this show we
want to build cultural uh cultural
products right netflix is woke garbage
they're they're caving into these
protesters we're not going to do that i
want to make content
maybe you know i'll say this i fully
plan to be bigger than netflix 15 years
maybe we'll see where we're at in five
years but that's the goal this this will
all come to culmination with this
ridiculously large streaming or digital
or vr whatever platform it becomes
tales from the inverted world is our new
project mysteries paranormal true crime
we can come to uh occult on that at all
oh definitely absolutely great right now
shane cashman the host and writer is is
um i don't know if he's still in georgie
he went to georgia to track down the
lost confederate gold after the war
ended where did they hide it right and
he also uh i don't want to spoil too
much but my understanding is he
personally witnessed the ufo with a
group of people who are hunting
he's got a bunch of civil war ghost
stories so we're gonna have like this
huge array of civil war ghost stories
sightings cryptids conspiracy plots
creepy history stuff
and
we are heavily investing in this show
with the staff
so we have to get the youtube channel is
new so to put it mildly investment means
not
making money right in the red we want to
get to that black so evan if you really
do want to help support a show like
tails from the inverted world and help
us make more of it if you become a
member at tim cast they're just
different tiers like 10 bucks a month
gets you all access to all the content
25 bucks or more gets you free tickets
to our events when we when we have these
events we're planning to do an event
once every month probably going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger and then if
you really want to support the show and
you're really digging the show
help us make more of it right now um
jessica is doing the art for the visuals
of it and it is a grueling endless job
if we could hire more people that would
be absolutely fantastic so that would be
great well i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention while we're on the subject that
don't dabble with the occult don't mess
around with ouija board don't trust
witches i love the occult i find it
massively interesting the goesha the
study of demonology
yeah so here we go i didn't i didn't
know this jeff rock says tim is talking
about vito who hosts biggest problem
with dick masterson who would be
hilarious to have on i didn't know i i i
saw dick i didn't know if it was for
sure him and i didn't realize the other
guy was a part of his show so the people
at netflix for those i don't know is the
guys who do the dick masterson's podcast
maybe they were filming something then
i feel like they were legitimately
defending dave chappelle i mean i'm sure
they were having fun with it no no i'm
saying but i bet you they were probably
filming while they were doing it so they
probably have like something on their
end as well yeah maybe i mean the videos
are ridiculous these people are insane
uh someone mentioned let me see
uh
jr was a member he said just watch the
video the lady shaking the tambourine
was shouting repent mfr
but that that's actually we've talked
about that before when i've come on that
they've they've turned all of this into
a religion
it is a theocracy that they're trying to
institute across america across the west
um it is a secular theocracy and i've
talked about this before that
progressivism is uh is
you know it's it's secularists trying to
outrun nihilism because they don't want
to stare into oblivion but they've
killed god and they've taken god out of
everything which is why the constitution
doesn't work anymore and laws don't work
anymore as you were talking about so
they have to replace it with a new kind
of god a secular kind of god and that
becomes progressivism that becomes
woke-ism all the
says john stewart had ron paul on the
daily show when fox was pushing mitt
romney and he did support him and bring
up how there was unfair media bias
against ron paul again yeah not perfect
i i understand your criticisms of them
uh but he did kind of speak out against
the orthodoxy sometimes
all right the roz rodriguez says jack i
love you you are my favorite on twitter
until i got permanently banned
uh follow me on getter then get on get
on getter getter is you know a great
workaround from this apparently trump's
doing something now too so we don't need
to be on twitter anywhere but thank you
madruk thank you and god bless you
sensei 2020 says tim you need to have
colleen a colleen noir on just one time
a big 2a advocate and lawyer out of
texas would be a great show uh open
invitation yeah always has been yeah we
should
follow up i want to get the ak guy hey
but we got free damastan now yeah yeah
so we need to build the range out but
this is west virginia more than enough
land for for uh for a nice shooting
range and then maybe we can have someone
come out uh maybe colin and you know
chris in the new range once we get it
done yeah
so apparently there's a big excavation
happening nearby and they have a big
sign saying free dirt ooh
so let's take some of that let's use
this we're super excited we're going to
get all the dirt shipped over to make a
giant backstop yeah it's going to be
awesome it's going to be absolutely
medium along the um along the sides as
well
yeah definitely we're gonna make a it's
gonna be awesome tim kennedy would be a
great guest too i think yeah all right
all right let's see what we got here
xerxzerk says josh was a father to very
to very young children
head of the i.t department humble
incredibly nice very intelligent loving
etc cancer does a horrible job selecting
victims as if they deserve it well sorry
to hear man screw cancer
yeah bad stuff
all right theodore herrera says jack i
have video of my sister who is a nurse
being escorted out of her place of work
she was told she had to wear extra ppe
because she was not vaxxed she had
religious exemption hi ian i like that
last part yeah
hi so she
yeah my question was send me the video
because i'm i'd be
if she was asked to wear more ppe did
she not want to wear the more ppe like
why would she escort it out i want to
hear when you hear the rest of that
story so this is uh from theodore
herrera i suppose if i don't know she
tweeted you or something uh just just
shoot me a message at human events there
you go
all right mitchell dodd says jon stewart
has a new show on apple tv last week's
episode was called freedom where he
argued in favor of government mandates
over personal freedom oh okay i would
like to just stress this point one more
you argued in favor of government
mandates when people john stewart ladies
and gentlemen
when people say but what about the other
vaccine mandates we already have in
place the response is
that's not true there aren't any there
were mandates for children going to
school never for you to go to mcdonald's
right if you want to buy your big mac
and walk in no no one was forcing you to
undergo a medical procedure to do so
that's new i want to watch re-watch this
uh john stewart on tucker carl's on what
was his crossfire
it was bad because it was when tucker
still wore a bow tie and john was like
look you're like a trained monkey you
look like you're wearing the boat john
stewart and shut down the ability for
people on the left and right
to talk to each other i did see tucker
had sort of an evil attack that tucker
like came out of that as a new man and
kind of like evolved his style of
reporting
so
i i like that i thought it was great
we'll do it we should do it we'll
literally just do it here a show yeah we
have we have two studios now and then
we'll just book people and i think if we
go for if you know if the show is not
based upon having ultra high profile
individuals we could easily make this
show happen a once a week crossfire get
like a prominent activist from the left
and the right to sit down and have a
conversation yeah it doesn't even need
to be billed necessarily as a debate it
would just be like but like hey let's
talk let's sit around the table and
actually talk some of this stuff out
yeah let's do it we'll bring it down how
magnifying glasses work and john
stewart's not invited no no john no but
if you had the opportunity to debate
john stewart would you take the
opportunity to do so no i would take it
but not on this because we're going to
call it the not john stewart's show
yeah the jon stewart is bad new
crossfire show yes no we can have him on
but i'm not going to cave and cancel the
show because he complains about it
insult somebody yeah exactly i do i do
think tucker uh in that clip
poorly responded too i think tucker's
like 35 in that clip like that was
that's a very young tucker if uh
when i saw
malcolm nance and ben shapiro i also
thought ben funny when he said he sleeps
on piles of money but also responded
poorly my response would always just be
like
i don't know why you're being mean like
i'm just trying to explain right malcolm
nan's a guy who's made an entire career
about lying about his military service
um the guy was he was an i.t guy like
you know and he was a linguist who got
kicked out of being able to even do that
and then just passed around until he
eventually left tucker tucker should
have said to jon stewart you know uh i'm
sorry you feel that way john i'm just
asking for a little bit of respect if
you'd like to he took it like a man he
listened to john he didn't insult him
and then he like just became a fantastic
yeah tucker carlson said what is this
this is ridiculous you're supposed to be
funny you're not making us laugh you're
supposed to be a clown oh yeah it was a
terrible reaction
he should have said john i think it was
good for him though at that time because
he had been doing terrible work before
that i remember when we when we had wash
and charlie on i i saw a lot of people
tweeting about how charlie was like
saying things to vosh
that like we're calling him out for you
know just like
things vosh has been criticized for and
i'm just like i'm not i don't care about
that i want charlie to be like this
policy doesn't work for this reason and
then people be like wow wash was wrong
about that
so i mean and there's a i'm not saying
not trying to specifically target
charlotte just saying that was one of
the things that came up i don't like
shows where it's just like i'm going to
talk about a person yeah so when i saw
malcolm nance and ben shapiro i'm like
ben should have when malcolm nance was
like is this what you do on your show
cause it sucks my response would be like
okay
sorry i guess like i'm just trying to
have a nice conversation man you know
you don't gotta yeah you i think you
would eventually win the argument that
way because even if you're not
necessarily it doesn't seem it's it
feels counterintuitive right well
someone said something so i have to
respond right as opposed to just saying
whoa man i'm just trying to talk about
this issue i i don't know why you're
doing it one of one of the number one
responses i give to people on facebook
when they're arguing is i'll just i'll
just be like i'm sorry i don't
understand why you're being so mean to
me right now yeah and that immediately
like most people go like well i don't
know i'm just saying and it's like dude
i'm not trying to have a fight i
remember during occupy wall street a
friend of mine went on sean hannity and
hannity said something like you're down
there the occupier's taking dumps on
cars and then my friend was like oh you
can't blame us they're arguing and i was
like dude why would you do that you know
what i would you know what i would have
said hannity your one wasn't correct
like that that guy is a photo of a guy
taking a dump on a car nobody's happy
about that gross we need help we need
some leadership that's true we need your
audience and people who support you to
come down and recognize that these big
banks are running us running us across
the coals that there's their special
interests that are working in government
revolving door policies and when you see
photos of this stuff know there are a
bunch of young people who are
desperately trying to say we want to
help the working class we want it we
want freedom we love america why don't
you help us out yeah but see that
message was completely lost because of
the other stuff and i've even gone back
and i wrote a whole book about antifa
and all of this and when you look at it
now the way things have changed here we
are 10 years later it's literally the 10
year anniversary of zuccotti park that
it's almost like the sides have flipped
in a way so antifa is now on the same
side as citibank you've got antifa and
brisbane australia calling for vaccine
mandates calling for more lockdowns but
also saying they're anti-fascist no no
no you are now the shock troops of the
political class you're the shock troops
of blackrock and blackstone and wall
street and all the rest of it whereas
you've got other people now that are the
deplorables saying you know what we're
on the side of the workers so it's it's
kind of like you're saying though you
know so many of these issues get caught
up in the left right of it but it's not
actually left right it's up down
yeah yeah yeah all right short round
says matrix four is probably about neo
convincing everyone to get back into the
pod and eat the bugs to heal the planet
trailer looked awful yeah absolutely god
awful halloween kills was god awful too
by the way i watched on the plane is so
bad oh man
you know what it is it's because look at
netflix look at their employees
garbage deranged yeah i'm not saying
that as a pejorative i'm not saying that
as like an insult i'm saying literally
to group people who are mentally unwell
screaming
and just
deranged so chuck dixon um the guy who
created bane he did birds of prey he
also i don't mean this is a plug but he
i got to work with him when i did the
ancient posto graphic novel um he had a
great youtube that he did the other day
where he was talking about why it is
that dc and marvel can't write stories
anymore he said because they get so
caught up in
character development but not just
development deconstruction of character
and they deconstruct and they
deconstruct a little more then they
deconstruct a little more and it all
becomes all about the identity of the
character that they don't create any
stories because they never could because
they didn't actually have any talent
because deconstructing something isn't a
talent it's just taking something that
already exists and then reducing it to
more base layers as opposed to having a
story about superman or batman going up
against an adversary and having to
defeat that adversary
instead you're just deconstructing the
character and eventually you're turning
it inside and inside and inside that you
go completely inside out and so he's
just they're just destroying them
like wolverine he'd be there and then
something would happen and he'd be like
i'm devastated and then it would that'd
be the end but now it's like i'm
devastated and then the next frame is
because of my childhood and then like
goes into why he's yeah no one cares
about it
all right max jones says nice harmony
silhouette on the wall is that a new
acquisition it is indeed aha
yes yeah we have a whole new music setup
if you watch the cast castle vlog you
would see them setting it up so we can
we actually have a piano uh
electric piano we've got bass there's
two guitars there one guitar there
there's another guitar sitting over
there and uh we've got a microphone so
we can actually do jam sessions yeah
there it is which we're playing we have
another mixer board which goes into our
other mixer board so we have all the
sounds come together and that'll be the
whole third the whole third hour today
it's just jamming yeah well we used to
we used to jam on friday nights we might
do something like that but the actual we
had a plan to do events where you can
actually have tickets to come here but
that seems to be jammed up because of
like legal issues about the jam
paperwork issues so i want to get jack
out here on fridays from now on so we
can rock and roll after the show
i want to get jack on bass you know i'll
play guitar uh sydney watson she plays
piano right right and she sings yep uh
ivory hecker plays guitar and um ryan
long plays drums
and i got the triangle james horse of
course ryan long's a drummer of course
he is yeah uh james he does does he sing
or he does sing he sings yeah he sings
broadway yeah he seems well so getting
making this super group and
we should we should we'll do like rage
against the machine but like the current
version yes we should cover it's killing
in the name right right but we should
make submitting in the name yes
f you you better do what we tell you
rage with the machine on behalf of rage
for the machine on behalf of rage on
behalf of the machine range on behalf of
the machine
all right let's read a little more
michael weston says oh excellent name by
the way um is your burn notice elective
what's the status on the freedom phone
actually by the end of the series i'm
pretty sure that was over also with
creating culture would you consider
doing an episode of what servers
services and other products to use to
avoid being canceled by the likes of
amazon google etc
um well we're working on a bunch of
shows we have a pop culture show we're
working on talking about just movies
video games and you know cultural issues
around that so
we do talk about those issues like
obviously talking about dave chappelle
and stuff this one would be more like oh
britney spears conservatorship and the
one story i really don't care for gaby
potato
but if that's it's you know more
cultural side of things alligators
freedom phone is on a huge wait list i
think right yeah and we're having
trouble purchasing them it's for some
reason things cards were getting
declined like i was using multiple cards
to try and buy them i don't know if it's
on their end or they haven't supplied
issues like everyone else i know that
the demand orders say they're going to
ship in 20 in november of 2021. they
were too big yeah
yeah we
and we can't ask for special treatment
right because you could get a a potemkin
phone right so we need to have an order
from people they won't know who to see
and then right right you can source it
otherwise it wouldn't be legitimate but
thanks for reminding me i'm gonna try
and order those again
bazinski says luke was theorizing that
maybe plastic pipes that carry water
leak bpa and there's a lot of soy
lethesin that stabilizes all kinds of
processed food
that's true yeah
good to know
brian knowles says tim if they are
starting to mandate medical procedures
such as vaccines who's to say they won't
mandate things such as birth control
remote imagine if when you were born
they say would you like to do their you
know
you know medical implant while we're
here and the parents are be like oh
absolutely and they put the chip in and
the chip can release a
series of hormones or whatever for 16
years
and then
they can just type in a nap and control
what happens it's not crazy to think
that it won't happen yeah it's like
we're um it's crazy to think that it was
right so my son's uh my older son is
three now and so we're going through
potty training and
you know he's
pretty good for the most part but he's
still you know there's accidents
occasionally and it's like oh well
instead of me just having to father him
and discuss these things with him it's
no no it's just just dial it in better
man just just take away some endorphins
you know and then if he goes then adds
it's ridiculous but i could totally see
people saying oh i'll just use this app
to control my phone that'll be or troll
my son that's so much easier than
actually having to you know be a parent
and you're probably gonna see things
like
help your kid learn learn languages
faster put a chip in his brain and they
really will learn the language you know
which one i would take though honestly
i would yeah that does happen on
stargate when the little kids get the
implants yeah download their memories
but then when they remove the implant
the kid becomes comatose but then the
implant can be shared with all other
people so they all share in the
knowledge and experience of that live
mind creepy
yeah you're you're giving away your
individuality with these things all of
these things desiree smith says why is
there an adorable llama plush behind
poso it's an alpaca it is an el paso it
is an alpaca and the scarf is made from
alpaca wool yeah oh it's very cute thank
you alpaca there's a little a little bit
it's because jack didn't have a book
yeah well it didn't bring me away you
didn't tell me about the shelf
i didn't know
i would definitely would have put the my
pillow there by the way it was john r's
idea he super chatted and saying why
don't you put a shelf right there for
people it's actually a really good idea
yeah i was like that's a good idea
because we have um we have like the uh
we do like the bible story by
like a smaller my pillow that you can do
and it's like full you can bring a
little white pillow yeah there's no
really but if they have like they have
bible stories you can get so like we
have the one for my kid we have um uh
like the nativity story and you can get
like noah's ark you can get the other
lions then a bunch of different ones um
they have like patriotic ones as well
you know necessarily religious but you
know just a bunch of cool different
designs but it would totally fit like
right on that shelf all right
ugandan dinner says tim your response to
people saying the increase in gas prices
isn't related to biden i would say
they're lying i mean first of all you've
got completely stable destabilization in
afghanistan but let's just start from
the beginning joe biden banned fracking
on federal lands joe biden shut down the
keystone pipeline
with that alone we saw a major spike in
speculation that a decreased supply and
an increased demand with drive up prices
so aside from that fact which is going
to increase prices you had speculative
demand on top that drove up gas prices
now you have a trucking shortage and a
labor shortage which yes has a lot to do
with joe biden's failed policies the
jamming up with the ports yes major
problems the build back better bill look
that's not happening yet but yes joe
biden's policies are resulting in
everything getting worse
not to mention i can put it very simply
when it was donald trump that 2020 was
all trump it was trump's responsibility
as president he was in favor of you know
slowing slow the spread 15 days he was
in favor of a lot of these policies he
came out and criticized them later but
the ball had been rolling and 2020 was
bad economically and i think a lot of
people recognize covet as for joe biden
i'll absolutely recognize the the impact
cove and everything's had but when you
have a guy who says we're going to do a
vaccine mandate people believe he puts
an executive order in place because
there's a complicit media he doesn't
then they start firing people when
you're already dealing with a labor
shortage my friends then you have the
democrats planning on pumping out more
and more money spending more
inflation
also drives up gas prices so so you just
spare me take the and i'd say this for
both sides by the way because you see
republicans and democrats getting this
wrong you got to take the alaska pill
you have to take the alaska pill we have
so many rare earth minerals there
gas we have the natural resources occupy
alaska invade alaska whatever it takes
you know and it's yeah we went up there
with daniel turner and learned about all
this it's you know i i want to get
greenland too by the way definitely
invade greenland while we're at it yeah
but you get both of those and we don't
need to worry about afghanistan we don't
need to worry about the world island we
don't need to worry about any of these
things we'll have everything we need for
the next hundred years
or more right on
all right i love how they uh made fun of
trump when he was like we should buy
greenland it's a great idea it was like
actually was a very smart thing yeah
yeah so now china is getting in there
and you've got bill gates
and
um bloomberg and bezos i believe are all
going in on rare earth mineral mines in
greenland which could have been ours it
could have been ours remember when trump
tweeted the trump tower in greenland not
to do this yes
just do it just take it awesome
all right let's see what are the danes
gonna do about it denmark owns greenland
why don't they just call it denmark
excuse me excuse me we need to liberate
the greenlanders from the oppressive
white global colonizers yep
let's make it a hallmark that's right
make it a human park it'll be the first
and denmark's monarchy
dude i think they should change the name
of greenland to denmark at this point
oppressors because it's so beautiful and
huge
it's green and if they own it are you
saying that the danes are beautiful and
huge of course yes okay psychically all
right all right let's see kyle sheridan
says luke some shirt ideas one with
thomas payne's quote from the american
crisis socialism is a human rights
violation and the wolf of wall street
meme with pelosi's face over leo's body
i like it good idea i love the ideas
people send me ideas all the time and
that's how i'm able to make some of the
shirts so you guys could email me at
instagram
there's several there's so many games
yeah send me all your ideas info we are
change.org i'm going to take that back
greenland's an autonomous territory
within the danish realm so maintain your
independence green lunch okay all right
everybody smash that like button if you
haven't done it already and go to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have a members only segment coming up
it'll be published around 11 or so pm
you don't want to miss it and also as a
member you can bid to get two tickets to
come to our show this saturday and i'm
just gonna let you all know uh we don't
really have a plan you know like we were
like hey we should do an event i'm like
yeah and so i asked this venue and they
were like i guess and i was like cool
and then i was like so what do we do i
don't know ian's like we should jam and
i'm like okay and then i was like oh
i'll see if we can get like ryan to do
comedy and so i hit up ryan and he's
like yeah we could have danny open i'm
like cool and then i'm sitting here this
morning i'm like jamming you know it's
like i i play guitar to warm up my my
voice before i record and then i'm like
i have no idea what we're doing this
weekend for the city like i know that
ryan is going to
perform uh people we're gonna have
tickets but i mean like
i guess we'll just be hanging out you're
going to meet me
yeah it'll be fun but answer some
questions how does everybody ask
everyone maybe maybe we sit on stage and
just say questions or something that's
funny yeah for like an hour or 30
minutes or something yeah castle live
that's right yeah we're actually
thinking about getting a bigger venue
but you call it tim cast irl irl we
could like
we were thinking that yeah record it and
put it on the website uh the q a
yeah definitely yeah from the audience
and uh i don't know what do you think of
it i don't i i want to like start a
march a chant i want like some kind of
like civil disobedience that's not
environment i want some kind of like
found the fed found the fed everyone
non-violence non-violence yeah this is
gonna be like having chicken wings the
fed's calling me a fed come on
what is this i saw that everybody in the
chat oh the fed is back
all right everybody smash that like
button you can follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me at tim cast
basically everywhere jack you want to
shout anything out maybe a pillow or a
book yeah no no i've talked about my
pillow um but you know with the supply
chain crisis with all that stuff coming
from overseas your my pillows are made
right here in the united states so
support american workers buy american
beat the supply chains beat china go to
mypillar.com utilize promo code posto
and then also check us out on uh the
human events daily podcast powered by
turning point usa
ton of stuff going on with turning point
huge event coming up in december we've
got tucker we've got candace we've got
kaylee we've got junior we might have
another guy with a similar last name as
junior coming up as well as myself
that's going to be phoenix december 18th
to the 21st right on i want to thank all
the people in the chat that called me a
gorilla today yes and if you enjoy my
ramblings about bill gates's microchip
contraceptives you will enjoy my channel
uh which is very close to 1 million
subscribers the channel is called we are
change and we're only 250 900 559 people
away from one million subscribers and i
think it would be ironic to get a gold
plaque when youtube still hasn't sent me
my silver one
luke is the og demonetized yeah yeah one
of the first channels ever do you mind i
think you were the first yeah seriously
before demonetization was a thing they
were manually going into luke's channel
yeah turning off ads they didn't even
tell me and everyone like like i had a i
had a green uh
i had luke's fault i had a green dollar
sign and then and then it's like nothing
like no review
no questionnaire no options just like
blank i was like what the hell's going
on here i talked to people at youtube
they're like well we don't know
what's going on here no it never it
never hit anyone else so uh yeah channel
is uh youtube.com forward slash when we
are talking about
patients
yeah when i was uh making youtube videos
in 2007 when they released the partner
program or was that 2008 they uh they
just looked right over my stuff but all
my friends got monetized but they didn't
like my stuff people could chat with
screaming a lot of women well you were
you're going crazy
i will wear that badge till the end uh
thanks for coming i love you guys thank
you for your comments your messages you
subscribers everybody you guys make this
a completely unique experience don't
don't forget
if you go to timcast.com and go to the
about section there's a p.o box
and whatever you send to luke yeah must
put on his that was that was last week
oh yeah
i mean the wall's already filled
yeah i mean look how many posters i got
thank you for all the posters by the way
they're incredible and they're awesome
the one with lucas bill clinton was
great yeah that was hilarious that's a
like i didn't want to show it
yes that was a great photoshop job but
even a better troll so yeah if you guys
just make sure yes
when you do send stuff to the house make
sure you address it to the people you
want it to uh to send it to it gets lost
and before it gets lost and i i
appreciate any kind of uh housewarming
gifts i appreciate it very much it means
a lot yeah and send stuff to anybody
whoever yeah
we also have uh i'm here as well and i
was gonna hark back to the note that we
made about tales from the inverted world
because i was listening to that while i
was taking a walk the other day and that
is a super cool show he gets into it and
he talks about a bunch of the history
and all the different stuff that's going
into each episode he really does a lot
of hard work on it shane does and i
really recommend it highly so i i just
want to say real quick yeah with tests
from the inverted world these are like
just like some preliminary essays that
shane had written and the the the stuff
with the the ghost stories i get a
message and he's like i just saw ufo i
swear to god
talking about they went they went ufo
hunting yeah and i'm really excited
because i've seen some of the uh the the
details on like the lost confederate
gold and it's like it's like national
treasure but like you know for the
confederates that's awesome no for real
like there's crazy uh uh like myths
about what they did with their gold this
is like a huge thing like what you know
what happened buried under a cemetery
maybe all sorts of dispersed to a bunch
of churches series
but yeah i had to hit up the whole
family chat and be like you guys need to
check this podcast out this is how tim
cass is expanding and this for how we're
going to make a difference in the
culture but you guys are more than
welcome to follow me on twitter at sarah
patrick's where i attempt to change
culture in weird ways we will see all of
you over at timcast.com in the member
segment thanks for hanging out bye guys
you